so there was a UFO to hear uh UFO
hearing today and I got to tell you it
was one of the most boring things I've
had to listen to when I had a playing in
the background and eventually I just
turned it off but there were some things
that I found interesting the first thing
I'll say is I don't believe any of it I
think I don't trust these individuals
they're testifying I think uh they're
misleading people and uh factual but not
truthful in how they describe things
let me just say
Hunter Biden was facing a plea agreement
it fell apart the judge threw that there
seems to be some very serious back room
dealing going on that they could not say
on paper or in court and the judge kind
of figured it out and everything's
falling apart and then surprise surprise
a UFO hearing happens where some guy
says that non-human biologics have been
recovered from off-earth technology I'm
not going to bury the lead
a a weather balloon with a cat in it is
off Earth Technology piloted by a
non-human entity okay so unless they
explicitly say it but anyway I digress
based on the context of the conversation
when asked about non-human pilots and he
said yes yep and then said off Earth
Technology
he there's no way he doesn't know he is
confirming the existence of aliens
okay and he may be trying to manipulate
the public I don't know but we will talk
about it I think it's silly but trust us
the conversation will will be dabbling
in the political because we'll be
talking about how they want to distract
us from what's really going on and
that's the hunter Biden story we also
have big news Mitch McConnell appeared
to have either a stroke or seizure on
live television at a press conference he
froze and nobody could make heads or
tails of it I think it may have been
what's called like an absent or absent
seizure some people say it may be a um a
TIA I forgot what it stands for uh a
mini stroke they call it but we'll we'll
talk about that one for sure and there's
a couple other stories Kevin Spacey was
found not guilty some people have said
this proves it's me too garbage others
say nah it's just he's getting away with
it but uh before we get started my
friends head over to castbrew.com big
announcement yo we got new flavors you
can join the cast Brew Coffee Club you
can get ground or or whole bean and
you'll get three bags per month if you
join the coffee club or take a look at
this we got Mr boca's pumpkin spice
experience Appalachian nights the new
Blends sleepy Joe decaf now available
and we have stand your grounds and
medium roast unwoke decaf that's right
we're all very clever shout out to the
timcast members who are helping us come
up with names for some of our Blends
they're all available now and if you
want to support the show you can buy
coffee at castbrew.com because that's
our company we sponsor ourselves also
head over to timcast.com click join us
become a member and you can actually
call into the members only uncensored
show Monday through Thursday around 10
pm we take calls around 10 30 p.m we do
four or five every night if you've been
a member for at least six months or you
sign up the 25 per month level you can
submit questions and potentially call
into the show that we will have one of
those up tonight around 10 pm it's a lot
of fun so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about all of this and more is Lila
Rose hi Tim
who are you I am Lila Rose I'm the
founder of live action and I don't know
if aliens exist or not that is an
interesting topic so I don't have a ton
of opinions except it would be fun to
meet an alien yeah maybe unless they
like are trying to experiment on people
or something you know that would be a
problem we don't we're not particularly
nice to non-human entities when like in
reference to cows and and stuff like
that we're not nice to human entities
and that's so live actions focus is
protecting humans and what never makes
the headline is that 2500 humans
children in the womb are killed every
single day legally in the United States
good point
humans aren't good to other humans what
would aliens do so uh well thanks for
joining us should be fine thanks for
having me yeah we got Phil Labonte hello
everyone I am Phil Avanti lead singer of
the band All That Remains anti-communist
counter-revolutionary
I think that aliens are going to mimic
us so if we get our stuff together maybe
we'll have a better chance there there's
a theory that we're in a black hole so
everything that's going in is actually
coming into our universe from without I
don't know it's real or not Phil uh I'm
Ian Crossland and I uh Tim you mentioned
earlier that uh what's his name may have
suffered a TIA transient ischemic attack
yeah uh commonly known as a mini stroke
but anyway we're gonna do it on the show
good to see you Serge is back yes I have
survived my trip to Utah finally have a
license it's great uh I'm served.com
let's do it here we go we have this
tweet from drama alert former U.S
intelligence agent David grush confirms
under oath that aliens exist okay
technically he did in the context of the
question asked and how he answered he
did but I'm willing to bet he's that a
game is being played to distract us from
the hunter Biden news about tax
avoidance uh tax evasion and other
illicit business deals failure to
register as a foreign agent all of a
sudden we get this story which seems to
be nonsense but in the rare uh look it's
going to be really funny in 50 years
when they're like humans made contact
with aliens you know in the 30s or
whatever and it was revealed to the
public in 2023 but no one cared so okay
we'll we'll talk about this because it
may be big news but let me play this
video for you we have a rep Nancy mace
talking uh asking this question and it
is a is a good question where's our
audience our audio good let me get the
audio up and then here we go if you
believe we have crashed craft uh stated
earlier do we have the bodies of the
pilots who piloted this craft
as I've stated publicly already in my
news Nation interview biologics came
with some of these recoveries yeah
um
were they I guess human or non-human
biologics
non-human and that was the assessment of
people with direct knowledge on the
program I talked to that are currently
still on the program if you believe okay
I'll say it again I said in the intro to
the show
pilot it first of all she said pilots
and it seems like it kind of weaseled
past it yes we were she says did you
find piles he goes we've recovered
biologics yeah
does that mean we recovered the pilots
or does it mean like there was a leaf in
the vessel
he did not say look I'm sorry man if
you're trying to confirm the ages of
aliens you need to look Nancy Mason the
eyes and say ma'am
the vehicles or craft whatever they may
be appear to have originated not on this
Earth Technology we don't understand and
whatever creature or entity was inside
of it is unrecognizable to us then I'd
be like whoa even then I'd be like what
was it burned okay
non-human entity someone posted a
picture of an ant riding a leaf
so remember Barack Obama when he said he
didn't know when life began that that
was above his pay grade we don't even
know in human we don't even know when
human beings are yeah so there would be
a non-human biologic it beats us right
so he's saying they may have found a
fetus in the spaceship and they're alive
it's not a human that is a theory Tim
that is a theory I'm so jaded on all of
the the recent alien stuff so I'm just
not it's not fun anymore the god like I
don't think they're I don't buy anything
the government says anyways why am I
gonna believe this we've had in intense
advancements in microelectronics and in
metamaterials that are lighter than a
lot of them are lighter than air some of
them are we also have talking plasma
like Laser Technology that can
triangulate into points in the
atmosphere and create a plasma ball you
can move around rapidly on a radar make
it look like it's some crazy craft it's
just it's too much obvious advancements
to start pretending now 100 years later
that we're finally in touch with aliens
they try to pull this over on people in
the 40s 1940s with Roswell they said it
was a hot air balloon they said it was
balloon then all of a sudden they're
like oh no it wasn't a balloon it was a
it was an alien craft everybody what was
that what was the dog's name Leica
a non-human pilot of us of an off-earth
vehicle pilate is a that's very generous
I was a pilot very dog hit buttons it
could also be they store data in DNA um
so it could have been like a computer an
onboard computer piloting it that had
its data stored in DNA which is a
biologic it's an organic
uh carbon-based look off-earth
technology could literally mean a
balloon it's what's off the Earth you
know what I mean yeah it's manipulative
manipulative language and the dude
didn't bring any real evidence and he
and he danced around the issues but I
will add he did he uh not just him but
in the hearing they did imply that
people have been murdered to cover up
UFO information in the government and
that he implied aliens are trying to
harm human beings I I don't buy it if if
they're if you can so I'm not even sold
on the con on the possibility of an
alien craft getting from another star
system to our solar system like I'm I'm
not even sold on that but meaning you're
saying they're real they just can't
travel this far yeah I'm not sure that
that you can travel those distances but
that being said even if that's the case
right say we'll give that like if they
have the technology to do that to make
that Journey there is no way human
beings could do anything at all to stop
them if they desired whatever they want
to do we we could not do anything at all
they would be so Advanced so far beyond
our ability not it's not necessarily
true it's it's
assumptive you know there could be
um an alien species that focused all the
technological technological development
into Einstein Rosen Bridges and their
Communications can be lacking you know
their manufacturing could be more
lacking but you know it may be
surprising to another species that we've
so heavily developed communication
Technologies
the assumption that aliens will be like
people like bipeds with hands too second
law of Thermodynamics says that you
can't like that you have to like nothing
is created or destroyed like it's you
the or the law of Entry I mean like
you're not like all of of
all the evidence is that that things
break down you know the only
thing that that
has been able to expand upon itself and
replicate itself is here on Earth we
haven't seen that anywhere else well uh
there's there's negative entropy in in
you know like matter comes together
infusion occurs in Stars yeah over time
and it's to create more entropy than
than attributes the theory that's
confusing people say you can't get more
energy out of a system than you put into
it but people are assuming that systems
are closed there are no closed systems
in reality everything energy can always
come into you into your area from
further away but yeah I'm just trying to
so you can create systems like Fusion
pulls it in from outside I'm just trying
not to deviate because that that's way
too far off where we were what I'm
saying is in the event any kind of alien
life came to Earth for some reason it is
an assumption that they would be more
advanced than us beyond our recognition
but they could have sent like drone
craft with like a bio-organic machine as
the pilot yeah and with it's not
targeted so as soon as it enters the
solar system just crashes like they
could have it could be done well I don't
think I think we're just trying to fund
space force Russia launched that dog
into space it never came back did it no
of course dog and there's there's also
there's also
um
there's also a theory that
um Yuri Gagarin is that his name was not
the first guy in space he's just the
first guy to come back and the first
guy's base just whoop he's gone you know
whoopsie so look maybe a satellite
crashed and they called it off Earth
Technology with non-human entities I got
here I Googled it my friends what is a
non-human entity as defined by the
Library of Congress
fictitious characters mythological
figures deities legendary characters and
animals with proper names quite
literally
there could have been like a Marvel
comic book if he's trying to manipulate
to distract from the underbite and stuff
because these guys are Intel officers
sorry I'm I'm more inclined to believe
that there if you're if you kept my main
says what's more likely they're trying
to make sure nobody pays attention to
Hunter Biden they've been covering for
the Biden family for decades I bet well
that's a fact or aliens exist I'd be
like well the first one's a fact no
matter what so if you come to me and
tell me this guy's lying about alien to
distract us that just plays into what we
already know and it's probably true also
what about angels and demons
where is that in that definition so it
would be funny if the the craft that
they discovered was like a flaming
Chariot with an angel on it we know I
think there's a lot of evidence if you
want to look at things that are just not
out of out of the ordinary look into
exorcisms and the existence of demons
and evil yeah what do you think exorcism
is anyway it is ultimately call casting
out a demon like is someone having a
seat like a force in the name of Jesus
Christ and they're like they're letting
go of an old Behavior pattern and
they're having like a seizure while it's
happening or something it yeah there's a
physiological reaction absolutely that
is you can see happening I've never seen
have you ever seen one happen I've never
seen one happen but I know people that
have and I've talked to priests that
have done exorcisms and I've talked to
people who've been oppressed by demons
so you don't really see that talked
about a lot at the US Congress but
that's affecting a lot more people than
aliens right now you got an abortion so
it's a lot more to a lot more if you
talk to these hippie leftists they'll
say interdimensional beings you know
like you do DMT and then you see weird
beings and entities that offer you
things and stuff and I'm like crystals
like demons it sounds like you're you're
talking about what people have talked
about for a long time just in a
different way yeah I mean you can invent
sort of a system of what these things
are to you that fits your ideology or
your worldview but at the end of the day
I believe there's God he created human
beings
we have rights there's also angels and
demons demons are Fallen Angels God's a
person angels are persons and humans are
persons and then there's animals so the
the non-human entities and Aliens might
be Angels or demons
possibly I have thought about that
especially those reports from the
military seeing the the you know the the
you know UFO going really quickly and it
seemed faster than any space you know
craft could go like that could have been
maybe an angel you don't know or like do
angels have vehicles
they could if they wanted to that's our
bodies it wasn't Sheamus saying that
angels are not we are our bodies like
physical entities they're not just our
vehicles uh I don't know what Sheamus
was saying but if I understood correctly
like angels are not this like human
beings and angels are very like
different things but angels are not
physical beings it would not be a Bible
Spirit their only Spirit yeah so they
wouldn't recover they can appear as
biologics in order you know to make an
impact that's what happened like
the angel appeared so it looked like a
biologic but but that's not a word we
use biological using that because of
that no but I know it's like so why is
he saying that you know a car accident
and we discovered two biologics like
what does that mean are you telling me
that there's two victims I feel like
it's like they would normally use the
term like remains like that's they call
it biologic like calling it biologic is
weird but like in other contexts they
would say the remains of what we assume
would be a pilot yeah and it's I don't
understand I mean I'm not that I am
trying to look into their brains but
like that's that's the standard way they
describe stuff so I don't know but I
mean biologic is it like is it like the
alien just a paste is it that's what is
it like a goo a bacterial paste that
they worked on on a space station and
then they maybe you know the alien is a
space off-road vehicle it was a it was a
satellite that crashed with uh with with
mold it could have been a snail named
Joe like that's it it's the Russian dog
we found it as long as there's so much
crap going on in the with the White
House I'm not buying plus they lie like
Kareem Jean-Pierre will lie straight
away so why why do we think this guy
won't James Clapper lied under oath to
Congress
let me ask you what what are the what is
the agenda of these intelligence
agencies has it been to expose
secret information to the public or has
it been to protect the bidens and other
corrupt politicians to protect the
government my argument is there's a lot
of incompetency in government and so it
can look like random stuff that doesn't
make sense can look like some conspiracy
that doesn't really make sense but we
think it's targeting someone but a lot
of the times it's in competency that
would be my argument for a lot of
government bureaucracy there's also the
possibility that um these guys along
with someone like Bob Lazar I think his
name was right yeah
government has a secret base they're
doing typical experiments propulsion
normal stuff I mean new technologies
they want to scare our enemies China for
instance
if China knows exactly what weapons we
have
well then they're going to plan for when
you know they go invade Taiwan and how
they're going to fight us if now they're
asking themselves did they actually
recover alien technology if we go to war
are we going to go up against something
we don't understand
it could be that these guys are useful
idiots who are brought into a room and
shown you know effectively magic tricks
and they say this is top secret you
can't tell anybody but look at this and
then they see a levitation we have a UFO
leveling people right now and then he's
like I gotta tell everybody and then he
goes and he says what he can say but
he's really just being duped as part of
a psyop to make our enemies think that
we've got a higher level of tech than
they do but do you think there's a lot
less psyops and there's just a lot more
again incompetency mistakes human error
confusion chaos but how do you
accidentally swear under oath that
aliens exist well I don't think he did
he actually say that he just kind of in
the context of the conversation you can
make two conclusions he's lying to us or
he's saying aliens exist
the way maybe yeah the way he phrase it
I lean towards lying to us
but it's either that or he's literally
he's he's there's no honest way he's
claiming a dog was found in a satellite
you know our mold was found in in a
module that was in space he was asked
about non-human pilots and says yes
we've recovered them
hmm
how do you accidentally lie about that I
don't think I don't know no no you you
either intentionally love oh yeah maybe
he thought he was telling the truth like
babazar I think he really thought he was
telling the truth because they brought
him into a room with nine drones and
they they put a puppet of a green alien
and one of them in the seat and he
remembers seeing that and then they
probably had some wild meta material
that was vibrating so fast you couldn't
physically touch it because it was
creating force and he was like oh
because he remembers that part of it I
believe that's something about it
um and then he just got his hand on a
window yeah and then they get him to go
tell everyone that it was and then they
tell him it was from Zeta reticuli they
feed him some nonsense so that if he
ever does go public he'll feed the
public some nonsense yeah
and so this guy could be similar or he
could have been just blind think about
how they compartmentalize the Manhattan
Project nobody knew what they were
working on right so you bring these guys
in and you're you're building some kind
of technology and let's say it's not
even anti-grav or force field or alien
attack or whatever let's just say it's a
meta material that's um lightweight and
very very dense like you know very
useful
you don't want this guy whose job is to
file paperwork to know how you make it
in the event he leaks things so what do
you say
aliens here's a question what would
aliens think of us if they showed up on
Earth I don't know what do we think of
cows chickens well I don't know if
that's even the question because I you
know bringing it back to
children and how we treat children
there's estimates that we kill about 50
million pre-born children globally
tens of millions of reborn children you
have to understand what would they think
about that yeah
when you talk about that you have to you
have to acknowledge that the people that
are actually having abortions they don't
conceptualize it as killing they just
don't like you I know I know that that
you do a lot of people that are
listening to
um people that are pro people that are
pro-choice don't consider it killing
that's why they can do that's people who
get abortions and people who approach
Choice are two different things fair
enough okay people that are pro-choice
do not consider it generally and this is
a generalization but people that are
pro-choice don't consider it killing at
all they consider it a medical procedure
and that's why they want to make control
the argument the way they do I think
that's pro-abortion people I think the
traditional pro-choice like I said that
Obama does many of them do think it is
killing but the point that I'm making is
the people that find pro-abortion uh
because most people aren't Pro like Pro
abortion shouldn't find fair enough but
I don't know most of the left is
pro-abortion but most people most people
aren't I think there's a variety there's
a lot of different reasons and there's a
lot of different beliefs around it about
whether or not I'm actually killing
someone is it a someone am I just going
to put my head in the sand but the back
to the aliens question the fact is we
are killing as a society
globally I don't I don't know how tens
of millions of people and hey look uh we
got too many chickens in chicken city so
we gotta stop having more of them uh
they sometimes make more of themselves
mostly we incubate so now we're probably
going to give some away or something
like that or just move them to new
locations but we have too many
so so they'd see us as the lower life
form is what you're saying no not
necessarily I mean they would just be
like I don't I think it would be a
neutral question they'd say
uh it is it is they're they're calling
they're self-calling you know what I
mean the same as they call any other
species they call themselves and humans
are I think a lot about the brutal the
barbarism of humans like the this in
order to survive we have to kill we have
to destroy another animal or another
plant steal its energy yeah we have to
consume destroy and consume the thing
actually kill things to consume them and
like how horrific for an alien that
desires if an alien just subsisted off
of light and that was how they got their
energy they would look at us like the
most horrific evil creatures but if they
also consumed and destroyed to live
they'd probably look at us as equals and
be very concerned that there would be a
war so like I don't know if I if I Came
Upon a species that just annihilated
everything in its path to survive I
think of it as a disease
uh I I think not that humans do
everything in their path that's
hyperbole but the fact that we have to
kill to survive so there's a big
difference between killing a chicken you
know to eat to eat the chicken then
killing a human being
it is very likely that their technology
I would say it's the likelihood is 100
that there exists technologies that we
do not have access to Simply by the
nature of the chemical composition of
our planet
it's possible that if aliens exist they
came to exist on a planet that had more
oxygen or less nitrogen or something
like that resulting in a different path
towards technology they come to this
earth and they're like whoa this is very
very weird the aliens could be
squid-like they could be giant balls of
gas they could or you know like a thin
membrane or something and we exist the
way we are based on the chemical
composition of the planet salt water
there there is a an interesting argument
that alien life will be nearly identical
to humans
in that the evolution of the eye based
on what we think we know independently
occurred in a bunch of different species
for the same reasons light sensitivity
of cells and then there was a higher
rate of success with a certain shape of
certain cells and and you know
eventually the eye forms I watched this
really amazing documentary on it
it may be the case
that if we do encounter aliens they will
be very very very human-like they will
breathe a similar uh atmosphere why the
oxygen level of our atmosphere is
perfect for fire which you can use to
separate elements and at the basis level
we make Metals but eventually we've got
to the point where we're synthesized
also cooking food and stuff yeah yeah
cooking food more efficient production
but look at Dolphins this is the
argument that I find compelling as well
that that the forms might be like human
yeah the forms that that have inhabited
Earth are the likely forms that life
tends to make considering the conditions
in the universe no no but not tends to
make but would succeed in terms of
technological advancement thumbs all
possible thumbs very very smart they say
big brains but they will never smelt
because they're underwater and they
can't some Dolphins lose any of this
show right now they're like you son of a
like I wish I had hands I'd show
him but you can't sorry can't do it and
whales either big brain super smart they
can probably perceive things we can they
definitely can with sounds and all that
but they're not going to start a fire so
that's all they'll ever be but we are in
this auction-rich environment oxygen
actually destroys cells oxidization and
we've evolved to be able to exist here
and we make fire and then we throw stuff
in it and then that stuff melts and we
separate things and then we we extract
chemicals and hormones and now we have
computers and Rockets synthesizing
synthesizing fuels and all that stuff
my big concern is if aliens do exist and
they show up and they don't just
immediately kill us I don't think that
will happen but if they did show up we
would not do a good job or we would
really struggle Humanity at large right
now with how to treat them in an ethical
way because I think our bioethics
generally speaking today especially in
the Western World especially in America
are very broken and you look at
reproductive Technologies as an example
and cloning right and the ability to
clone and the question of you know can
you create a clone of yourself and then
take their organs can you what do you
how do you treat a cloned embryo you
know how do you treat embryos that are
being used for research there's all of
these ethical questions that we're not
getting right do you think we're
practicing the wrong thing we're killing
killing human beings you think clones
have souls absolutely if they're human
an individual human absolutely like a
different soul from you or like if
someone cloned you be like a different
soul well I mean identical twins have
different Souls but they're biologically
identical I just tweeted out a video of
a nano machine taking a firm and
impregnate in an egg with it and the
sperm's just like laying there I'm like
how many we have so many lazy people
already we don't need to take the lazy
sperm and make new lazy it's crazy
um but how do you think Lila like it how
do we solve for this bioethical problem
where we're killing young people because
it's like a resource struggle I feel
like if people don't without the
resources we can't support the young
we've always had to leave the weak and
suffering behind in the tribal life and
things like that because you can't
support it
um and it does terrify me that they're
impregnating eggs with weak sperm but
like how do you well it's funny with the
resource thing just to touch that for a
second we are we have more resources
than we've ever had in arguably human
history and we have the technology to
have more more people and support more
people as a planet than in the human
history and all the all the predictions
about oh the universe is you know the
world can't handle more humans you know
the malthusian ideology of we can't
we're gonna have to kill people off
because we can't feed the world that's
not come true because as human beings
have grown and pop the Earth our
Technologies has have our Mastery of the
world has but anyway separate from that
though I think the big question is
what's the correct way we treat each
other you know do humans have human
rights and if we have human rights what
are they and I think most people I don't
know your guys's position but I think
many people today would say yes we have
human rights even the United Nations
says there's human rights and so the
problem question isn't whether or not we
have human rights it's where is the line
what is a human right right exactly but
I think most people would agree that the
right to not be killed is a fundamental
human right because if you don't have
that you can't have any other rights
right and that is the pro-life case in a
nutshell if you're a human you have
human rights and the first human right
is not to be killed similarly our
Declaration of Independence you're
endowed by we're endowed by our creator
so we're created they're not given to us
by each other we get them from on high
we are endowed with these inalienable
rights and the first of them is life
liberty The Pursuit of Happiness right
so life comes first and all humans have
that right whether you're born or
pre-born it doesn't matter you're a
human you have that right I don't
believe there is a way that you can ever
really win this battle
and the reason is these aliens
pro-abortion individuals are desperately
trying to remove themselves from the
gene pool but you are desperately trying
to save them this conflict will result
in more and more leftist ideologies
pro-abortion ideologies emerging in our
current system this means that they can
vote and they will vote for policies
that allow them to terminate themselves
in the gene pool
ultimately then they will reduce the
pro-life element conservatives will just
have more influence and more children
but then they will stop abortions that
once they have the authorities like
abortions done which means the remaining
pro-abortion people will have more and
more kids and those kids will hold the
idology of pro-abortion until they get
too too many then they'll vote for
abortion and kill themselves again
interesting well I think I
hear you I hear you I think that if we
you know in like a game theory analysis
like that if that happened just that way
I can see your argument but there's a
lot of other factors at play which have
to do like with podcasts like yours
where people are getting new ideas
they're being exposed to different
beliefs maybe they were raised by
hardcore pro-abortion parents and they
always were told to be feminist and to
be pro-woman is to be in support of
reproductive Freedom which means to kill
your baby and that's what they were
indoctrinated with basically I'd argue
it's indoctrination but then they might
listen to a podcast on YouTube and they
all of a sudden their world is blown
because they get a new perspective on
things so you know the beauty of today's
crazy media world and just the diversity
that comes with that is that people are
exposed to different ideas regardless of
how they're raised so the question is
will the truth win out well my question
what is the truth and will the truth
went out yeah what is because you were
saying the right to human life I think
that's a good starting point for life
for humans but at what point is an egg a
human I I wonder like I'm like well if
it doesn't have a brain it doesn't have
a heart feet no when it's fertilized is
a sperm an egg is a sperm a human before
it fertilizes the egg is it a human
right when it's banging on the egg's
outer wall like is it only once it's in
and that first magical electrification
appears then it's when a human because
it doesn't look like a human when a uni
when a unique set of DNA is created Life
Begins because it's called I agree that
it's living I agree that it's living but
I don't think it's a human so sperm egg
fusion and you get a single cell embryo
that has its unique set of DNA nothing
like it ever before and that is going to
grow it's going to self-actualize you
can argue grow itself eating it needs
nourishment but it's going to start
exponentially developing more and more
cells developing that heart the heart's
going to beat it just three and a half
weeks it's crazy how early the heart
breaks six weeks you have brain waves
already so human life virtually all
biologists agree it's fertilization even
Peter singer who is that you know Pro
infanticide ethicist from Princeton says
it's after fertilization human life
begins not with a sperm or an egg you
know it begins at the sperm egg I think
the distinction you're making is a
person and life like so it's always
human because that's the classification
but when does it have personhood is what
you're talking that's also my question
but it's like it's human rights not
personhood if you're going to say like
when So You're Gonna Roll a ball down a
hill at what point does the ball start
rolling First You're Gonna you're gonna
push the ball along a flat surface and
then it's going to roll down but so if
you push it is it rolling down the hill
yet as it's traveling horizontally only
when it starts to fall down the hill
because
hold on you said is it rolling down the
hill if it's yeah you've got to figure
answers no exactly if it's going
downhill so is it a human well I'd look
at a zygote and I can't determine like
from what I've been told and maybe maybe
I'm wrong maybe this is not good
information you cannot determine uh a
zygote is it called a zygote from
another animal zygote so you can well
you can actually and and I mean maybe on
the naked eye looking at it's too small
to see so in that sense you can't but at
biologists know how do you know what
something is you look at the parents
right so a single cell embryo has a
human mother and a human father a single
cell elephant embryo has a elephant
mother and an elephant
we know it doesn't matter at all that's
just a deductive reasoning no no no no
no this question is nonsensical whether
or not you can recognize what something
is doesn't change what it is I can't
tell if it's gold or pyrite doesn't
change it from gold or pyrite if there
is a human life and you're like well I
can't tell if it's human or not that's
like saying someone who's got a
disfigurement may not be human no
they're human if it appears to be
something you can kind of play like it
is like if somebody because you don't
know what it is doesn't change what it
is
I agree with that but if someone comes
up to you a hologram points a gun to
your head and you think it's real you're
gonna probably there's something real is
not the same as whether or not it is
real think of it yeah but your body will
react as if it is but perception is
immaterial to the question of
objectivity I don't know because I'm an
IBM if I'm an IVF specialist right you
know IVF you're creating
um new embryos in a peachby dish to
implant them in a woman down the line
right but my big aha moment is when I
have achieved sperm egg fusion and I
have all these embryos now right and now
I have all these little embryos that I
can then go on and plant and they'll
continue to develop into ultimately some
of them we hope a full-term baby you
know I have huge issues with the ethics
of by of IVF I think it's very very
problematic but the point is you know
the IVF specialist knows I'm trying to
create a human embryo for these parents
that just pay me to do this right so I
think biologists are in agreement and we
know from you know the fact that there
have human parents this is a human it's
human it's a single cell single cell
humans are very very tiny doesn't look
like a human the way you and I look like
humans right but a newborn baby doesn't
look like you right I mean they have
this huge head and the line of thinking
we look different at different stages in
our development as humans we look
different and sometimes we're so small
you can hardly you can't see you but
that doesn't mean you're not there if
someone's suffering from what is it
called porphyria or whatever with like
the vampire Legend comes from if someone
someone has some sort of disfigurement
or whatever and looks inhuman for fear
so they would say it's not a human and
then they would not give it rights okay
that's wrong we've we've very uh in in
recent history understood this you may
not look human but doesn't change the
fact that you have human rights well now
I'm talking about chimeras okay this is
a real thing they're actually splicing
DNA from different animals crazy so if a
woman a human woman is gestating a
chimeric animal of some sort of human
pig hybrid or something is it a human
yeah it's a it's a it's the fact that we
are a good question it's a very good
question we are playing God with human
lives and in these you know Frank and
Stein like experiments that we're not
acknowledging any ethics around it as
guard reels and so we're doing this
insane stuff and I think it's opening
the door to all of these abuses abuses
of humans for sure there's a there's a
million Frozen embryos in IVF right now
a million children in deep freeze right
now let me ask you you said you said if
something has human if someone like a
chimera is a human
I I that's that's a good question I I
don't know I think we we have to if
they're part human DNA but then they're
part
um Apes I think we have to proceed very
very and we were able they were actually
able to live and be gestated right
that's a big question can they actually
live with human kidneys and a human
liver is that a human
no I don't think
in a human woman no no what if the pig
doesn't have kidneys but it has a human
brain
this is interesting I was just having
this debate with the YouTuber Destiny
about what constitutes a human being and
I was saying that it is you your brain
doesn't your brain is an important part
of you as a human very important it's
the central control center for your body
right but as human beings we are our
bodies and we are also our souls and
there's a lot of mystery to that in
terms of you know you can't you can I
think you can observe the soul through
nature in a lot of ways the actions of
the soul but when it comes to you know
if we were to create a somehow create a
chimera and we were able to do this I
mean it it's a complicated question
which is why I don't think we are going
there I mean it's the reason I think the
problem is we're I mean it's been done
but there's not an ability to develop
the the baby I think that's where it's
failing right we've grown animals with
human organs right right that's been
done I'm saying that this sort of 50 50
achievement 50 human DNA 50 some other
animal DNA from the beginning
that's fiction right right so so I think
if it has some human
um I would argue if it has like a human
kidney or something in a pig it's still
a pig so if that's human animal the
question is so it's it's a human brain
and it's hard as a human the the
intelligence of a 27 year old
can write and paint and do everything
communicate but you're like that's a pig
I would I would put special ethical
protections on that on that on that
entity because we are we are playing God
when we shouldn't we shouldn't be doing
that stuff it's bad it's wrong but if we
were to do it it would be wrong to
harvest that pig human's organs it would
be wrong to kill them I think we would
have to treat them very carefully the
reason and and not violate with the
rights of this of this this creature
that we should not have created like a
Frankenstein experiment that it's wrong
that we're doing it and it should be
banned it should not be done well but it
is I I'm not denying what you're saying
it's being done since it is being done
and that's what's and it's also to some
degree there's a lot of funding funding
this this crazy uh experimentation on
embryos and humans that is being funded
by the government and that's so horrible
so we are all completely aliens are
doing it you said earlier that um the
aliens are telling them to do it I don't
know but it's horrible and it shouldn't
happen you said the way you determine if
like a one one day old zygote is I think
it's the zygote is a human is by who the
parents or who are the parents that are
gestating the thing so if a if a human
woman is gestating a one day old zygote
of a chimeric animal you would just
assume it's a human because it's got a
human mother that's a faulty logic
that's an inductive reasoning that fails
at that point I don't I don't think
that's the case I mean back to the kind
of question of is it human or not like
if there was some possibility to have it
there be a human father but some like a
you know a monkey mother if that's
Humanity if that was possible right I
would say well I don't think that we've
successfully done that I think I think
we have it fails when we try uh it fails
when you when you have 50 50. it fails
with a female chimp with uh human with
male with human sperm but according to
Legend the Russians did it but the
reason the reason uh it's it's not been
done in public is because the public
would reject it good as we should I'm I
would I would bet a large sum of money
that China's already done it well listen
if we were if anyone is doing it and if
anyone is succeeding and doing it I
think we need to apply careful
um protection of whatever these
creatures that we are creating without
responsibility without ethics
um
irresponsibly we should treat them
carefully and with protection because
they are carrying an imprint of humanity
and I want someone to be very careful
with that one of the things that Tim
said I think is important the idea that
we can that we can ban this or weak and
stuff that is
absolute fiction why we ban ready
we don't ban China from exactly bigger
Muslims and concentrations this is not
about us what we do in the confines of
the United States
things that you're talking about are
going to have repercussions throughout
all of human like or for through human
history like because you're really what
you're you're getting into is what kind
of ways are people allowed to reproduce
What kind of people are allowed to
reproduce What kind of people are we
allowed to make when we reproduce
because in very short or order you're
going to be able to decide I want a
child with these traits those traits and
that's wrong and people you can say it's
wrong was that you can't stop it no you
can't begin people would say it's wrong
but it's coming in another country in a
place with different morals like whether
it be China or Mexico
they're gonna go to Mexico to get their
kids genetically engineered if the US
doesn't allow it then those kids are
going to grow up in the United States as
genetically engineered they're going to
have DNA from different species that's
implanted through some virus look they
just cured they cured a kid's blindness
with the herpes virus putting some genes
in or whatever it'll come to the point
where there will be some dude walking
around with cat ears or whatever because
because his parents were weird anime
people and then you're gonna be like
he's part animals you're not gonna be
able to tell billionaires that they
can't go to another country and make
sure that their children will never get
cancer like when you when you go when
you've got a billionaire or Millionaires
and you're like if you in in this
country you're not allowed to do it but
you can fly to whatever country in
Europe and they'll allow you to to to
edit the gene so your child will never
have cancer so your child will never
have this we'll never have any number of
genetic defects that you can guarantee
that it that your kids won't have
anymore you are not you are not going to
be able to tell people they can't do and
there can be ethical treatments
depending how it's done so I think
that's an important distinction to make
but back to the kind of question of well
they're going to do it anyways if it's
something that's unethical right that we
could all agree this is an unethical
thing like you know uh creating a 50 if
it was possible I don't think it is but
creating a 50 you know human and a 50
pig or something
I don't think it's on ethics
it doesn't matter but just because we
can doesn't mean we should right and the
whole point of a law the whole point of
any society any civilization is to have
rules of the road we don't live
physically without rules so what do you
do so when someone from outside the
United States is genetically engineered
and now lives in the United States we
treat them with dignity and respect one
thousand percent we can still we still
have a responsibility for in our country
and whatever country we are a part of
what this isn't just the United States
other countries are called to be ethical
too it's not like just Americans should
be ethical everybody should be ethical
and there's a lot of amazing countries
outside the United States that I would
argue are more ethical than us Malta as
an example has eradicated abortion in in
Europe so there's countries that are
more ethical than us in the west Chile
is a very pro-life Latin American
country
um but the point is we should be focused
on what is the right thing for our
society to do what's the role of the law
and then we should pursue that instead
of saying well technology is going to
figure it out and eventually we're
doomed to it think about nuclear warfare
right we we have nuclear weapons so we
could just say well we're all doomed to
die by nuclear weaponry at some point I
mean you could make that same argument
right but you could say well no if we
treat each other ethically and we
practice ethics and we have good rule of
law and good systems we can avoid mass
destruction
it's always been like War historically
not always but over time so I'm
concerned that a country will develop
super soldiers that can like see super
long distance shoot throw really far and
that they would invade and Conquer if we
don't have that same technology and
super soldier program that we've just be
concerned I think we can if we started
doing unethical things because another
country was unethical it's just somehow
compete with them we would die by our
own sword in the end
it's simple it's not worth the risk of
doing what's unethical just because
someone else is in the hope that you'll
save yourself because you're actually
killing yourself and then you cease to
exist and then you cease to existence
that's why it's better to go down in
flames doing the right thing in the end
what about the nuclear right okay so
right now Republicans are doing
literally nothing as Democrats indict
and criminally charge a whole plethora
of Republicans the the so
my focus in terms of all this is
cultural we need cultural influence you
need media influence and we seem to be
winning on that front Tim cast
Democrats resort to blunt force and then
you just get Republicans saying well
this may reach the level of inquiry
we'll uh we'll we'll have a conversation
in the committee about whether or not we
can inquire as to what this could mean
so in the long run you could argue that
without any meaningful resistance what
Democrats are doing then the Republicans
cease to exist but I have hope that in
the human heart is written the moral law
and I've seen this myself and even in
the most distorted depraved person
there's still that spark of the human
law and of goodness and if we can
cultivate that then we can get these big
bad Democrats in this scenario you're
talking about Tim to do the right thing
and so that is that should be the end
but also instead of helping people do
the right thing so because we're all
made and called to do the right thing
we're going to jump to uh political
medical news we have this story from
timcast.com Mitch McConnell abruptly
stops speaking freezes during press
conference friends the Senate minority
leader was escorted of the room by
Senator John Barraza of Wyoming let me
play this video for you it is saddening
and I would describe it as a seizure
potentially a stroke here we go
dessert oh sorry I gotta turn the audio
on bring it up no I just got to press
the audio there fortunately he doesn't
speak for 30 seconds
and a string of
that's it that's the video he says
cooperation a string of and then just
freezes it's I went to I went to a um a
fundraiser a long time ago political
fundraiser for seizure awareness
and this guy who suffered grand mal
seizures
uh was explaining how often he'll be in
public meetings or at work
and uh he'll freeze exactly like Mitch
McConnell did and people will laugh at
him
and he could he could die
and he was like Awareness on what
seizures look like is extremely
important because of Hollywood everyone
thinks you fall to the ground and start
spazzing out
some people said I think it's like an
absent or absence seizure absent seizure
where you just freeze and lock up and a
lot of people were tweeting that this is
maybe what it was apparently he said
that he got lightheaded and he was fine
and then went on to have like a normal
meeting afterwards or whatever but I
think what we're seeing here is
you know we talked a whole lot about
aliens in law and morality
our political leaders
they keep winning no matter what no
matter what because our culture is dead
because this country will just walk into
a booth and rubber stamp D or R without
a thought because it is a dead culture
so against them so they vote for Pelosi
they vote for Mitch McConnell they vote
for people who should have retired 30
years ago and I don't see it changing
unless there's a hard fall you think it
was TV that deadened culture
no no I think it's uh it's it's like
it's a straw side generational uh Theory
so I I would argue what you're
describing there's a lot of Truth to
what you're saying Tim and I think that
it is ultimately a spiritual sickness
that we are facing because we have lost
the plot like what is the point of human
existence is it to just take is it to
just you know become more powerful or
more perfect like what's the point of
human existence is it to love and to
serve and ultimately For Eternity for
God or is it to take and that difference
I think if people are kind of
wishy-washy on that they don't know what
their purpose is then we don't really
care enough and then we just you know
maybe stamp what you're saying D or R or
whatever it is we're going in and we're
not really caring enough to really fight
but I do think a lot of people are
fighting for the country right now and
they care and they're raising young
families I know my family we're raising
a young family we're passionate we care
about the future we think there is a
future and enough of those people if
enough of us do that we can change it
it's going to be painful and hard at
points but I think we can change the
country and make it better so I don't
think it's hopeless Dianne Feinstein
remember she gets she goes she's out in
the for well was it a couple months or
something how long was she out for and
then she's like I was here the whole
time
I absolutely despise these people
Mitch McConnell we can talk about his
politics all day and night and I'll tell
you oh I don't like he does this and
like he does that but there is nothing
that that gives me more disdain for this
man than this medical episode I have no
sympathy no empathy for his freeze up
for his stroke or seizure because he is
gripping on to the the to the a
leadership position that a younger
person needs to have to help this
country and he's incapable of doing it
but it's not just him it is it is it is
a problem in this country and all of
Congress where they're all it's just and
and look at who was running for
president we're gonna get Biden versus
Trump I think Trump's better than Biden
but even Trump is older it was one of
the big big reasons we were saying to
Santa's is probably better is that he's
a lot younger unfortunately I don't
think the Santa is going to be able to
pull it off because he can't seem to get
a hold of his campaign well here these
people need to leave you thin and of
itself I think is not the key but to
your point I think you know if you're
very to the point of having strokes and
you need medical leave you should take
care of your health and not be trying to
lead the country in this case but I
think think it's not just youth it's
wisdom and I think there's a crisis of
wisdom and that's where even young
leaders are terrible so it's not like
they just because you're young you're
better if you're young you could be even
more foolish McConnell doesn't seem to
have any real wisdom about him either
that could be true I will not argue with
that I mean I think he he has done some
good things in his career but I do think
I agree with you we need we need more we
need fresh not just fresh leadership we
need good good leaders we don't need
brains man calcified I don't know if
it's calcified pineal gland but we less
aspartame in people's diets less high
fructose corn syrup yeah corroding the
neural network
someone points out on Twitter any job in
this country you are 81 years old and
suffer a seizure they would say look
it's it's it's it's time you go home
right this is not the job for you in
fact can he even be driving anymore I'm
not trying to rag on older people but
there is a point at which you are too
young for a job and too old for a job
we're not going to put 12 year olds in
the coal mines we should be putting 81
year olds in Congress do you think we
have should do age limits now
it is a tough question because of the
rate of Technology it should be more
about capability I agree with that I
think if you're if you're struggling
with serious medical conditions just
like as you described from work you
could take a leaf so would it be
Congress that votes to have the other
Congressman removed if there's a medical
thing I I I would love I would love it
right now if uh Congress uh voted to uh
the Senate voted to remove Mitch
McConnell it's almost imperative
you know we're missing a Kentucky
representative right now Feinstein
should we should be out and McConnell
should be out and It's Tricky when
they've been democratically elected
right that is that is straight back to
what you were talking about earlier Tim
you know if we got into a system where
we get to just out people because we
consider them physically unfit but they
were democratically elected you know it
gets into no but you can't it's
interesting we remove people from
Congress all the time all right not all
the time it's happened a couple times
you vote to send someone home uh
I I wonder if the vague ramaswamy he has
he had a couple proposals one publicly
he said there should be a Civics test in
order to vote I'm not a fan of that I
don't think that makes sense what I
really like is you have to sign up for
the selective service if you want to
vote if you sign up for the Selective
Service it you get a voter ID and if you
have that you're allowed to vote and so
I think that will solve a great deal of
of our problems overnight Vivek actually
clarified on the show last week he
thinks when you turn 18 you don't have
voting register 25 unless you pass a
Civics test or do six months of
community service or military service so
it's either or
do you do I disagree so you don't like
this Civics test uh I'm not a big fan of
it I don't think I don't think it
necessarily solves the problem
see the thing is about signing up for
the selective Services you're basically
saying I'm willing to die for this
country and guess what it's a very
simple sign on the dotted line that no
Democrat would be able to convince a
run-of-the-mill urban liberal to sign
but every conservative would be like I
love this country
put my name down however a lot of people
are going to say I wouldn't sign up for
that this country is corrupt no no if
the voting base is just comprised of
people who have pledged their lives to
this country you are not going to have
these corrupt people because they can't
get elected yeah but you know crazy
president was like oh now all you guys
all you voters signed up for the
Selective Service we're going to war
because they vote because as only those
people who get to vote so when the
president comes in and says Ah Mission
initiating the draft it's those people
who say recall yeah any impeachment
anything that that like shrinks the
number of of ignorant votes uh I'm for
so limit voting like in any way possible
in my opinion I don't think that uh that
it requires service
um I do get where you're coming from I I
understand the uh the the the idea that
you have to have something on the line I
personally think that maybe owning a
business or owning Pro like something
like that because you can start a
business on with a cell phone so like if
you actually start a business and you
have some kind of skin in the game and
the barrier for entry is real low for
that and again I'm not saying it's
perfect but I'm I'm I just don't think
that that you have to go through you
know serving the country uh but you
don't should be signing up for Selective
Service does not mean you're going to do
any service oh okay so you're oh yeah
all right it means that if the United
States is invaded you you've pledged
your life to defend it yeah now a lot of
people argue that but the draft in World
War one two and the Korean war in
Vietnam I'm like no no listen my point
is this there's corruption right now it
may just be an idealistic perfect system
but imagine if the only people who could
vote meaning there could not be a
foreign invasion of Syria everybody who
had to go fight it were the people who
were voting they'd be like I'm not gonna
go do that so I'm voting against these
people everyone else who sits in their
Ivory Tower sipping tea being like we
should go to war for oil wouldn't have a
vote and and if they wanted to go they'd
vote and you know what they're making a
point where let's say you've got a 350
million people in this country only 175
actually choose to sign up for Selective
Service to vote and this is split vote
and 100 million say we want to go to war
for this reason and 75 say you don't but
that's the point of saying I pledge to
this system it's not always going to be
about what you want but you know
everyone else voting for it has pledged
the same thing as you and we don't even
have everyone voting though who I think
is well equipped to vote so this is
but I disagree with that entirely I
think there's a lot of people that don't
vote that I think should vote is what
I'm saying really yeah especially like
in the pro-life space and in the space
where people have values they love the
country they love what we were founded
on they believe in the future for the
country often yes many are active and
politically involved but the thing is a
lot of people who are doing that are
busy running their businesses and
raising their families and so maybe
they're not doing every election you
know maybe they're not as involved as
they need to be so we encourage more
Civic engagement right look look and
Mitch McConnell his biggest issue is not
I mean I hope he's well you know but I
think his biggest issue is a failure to
lead on fundamental human rights and the
Republican party has made some strides
because it's in our platform that life
begins at fertilization and that
abortion should not be permitted and
that legal protection is deserved by All
pre-born Humans Mitch McConnell has not
LED like that he's been squishy you're
the fastest way to get that is
exactly what I just said I I went uh
when I worked for these non-profits 15
some odd years ago they said anybody
here want to go see Death Cab for Cutie
live and I was like that's like my
favorite band I would love to go see
them live and they're like here's your
vinyl all access pass here's your stack
of voter registration forms you're gonna
walk around people register people to
vote but it gets you backstage access
and I was like yes and I walked around
back you want to vote you want to vote I
did not know their political affiliation
but come on it's Chicago they're all
Democrats
what if I walked up to them and said hey
do you want to vote and they went sure
I'll sign up just sign that you'll you
want to join the draft and fight in the
military no way I'm not signing that and
they'd leave and then you'd go to some
like country music event where some guys
weren't an American flag thing about how
he loves this country and you'd walk up
like anybody want to vote I'm like sure
would you would you sign a pledge saying
you'll fight for this country if we get
invaded and being drafted by I love
America and they'd sign it and then I
think that's a good thing
if you're not willing to serve in the
most dire circumstances meaning there's
no obligation in the immediate only in
the event of us being attacked then you
don't get to tell us how we run this
country I like that except if if all
these people sign up for the selective
service and then the president's like
we're going to war and they're like no
no no you're like well you already voted
for me it's called impeachment get your
get your gear and then the general step
in and it's like what are you gonna like
we're going to war like there's not
enough time when when the president
declares that's the president shouldn't
be declaring war first of all
happened overnight declare war right
and I also think you you're going to
have a greater alignment between the
people who are eligible for conflict
first of all there will still be a
military meaning a draft will not
necessarily occur
that that's the point it's a very very
simple solution that requires very
little other than commitment that
typically does not happen so you had
equally draft men and women in that
scenario women women can uh work in
factories and women can work in homes to
help with the war effort and have them
do the same job soldiers march on their
bellies
so if we don't put women in combat they
can certainly do all sorts of
infrastructure-based support work and
even maintaining households if you're
more I do I do think I do what I agree
with what you're saying is that we need
more patronism patriotism and a sense of
a shared project that this is our
country that we should care about
together and make stronger and better I
completely agree with that not sure
about that approach necessarily but if
there's a way we can the best way I
would argue to do that what I'm
describing that shared project is just a
lot of Education Shoring up good
institutions storing up the American
Family some of the best public policy
that I think we could be doing right now
is not affecting how we're voting but
it's affecting how we support the
American Family investing in the
American Family through child tax
credits through giving more support to
the American Family giving them
write-offs giving them more you know
even a subsidy give give families a
subsidy if you have a child you get a
subsidy especially if you're a married
couple you get a subsidy because we want
to encourage those things no taxes I
would say yeah that sounds great people
would have three kids that sounds good
absolutely or or like an 85 reduction in
your taxes or any something anything I'm
sorry I'm sorry married and three kids
no taxes they are our most precious
resource children they're treated like
crap in this country especially if
they're pre-birth and if we change that
and our public policy helped change that
I think there would be beautiful
outcomes because what what matters it's
not about our selfish individual
Pursuits so I want to do I'm not going
to have kids because I just want to
travel the world or whatever it is it's
about children are the future and
they're we learn how to love through
sacrifice and through service and
through responsibility to each other and
if we could encourage that through
public policy that'd be a beautiful
thing not to force it not to force it
but to encourage what if a couple of
businessmen a man and a woman get
together like yo let's have some kids we
don't even have to raise them we just
have them and then we'll get tax credit
and then they have kids the kids have to
be married they get married they have
kids the kids are criminals they're
horrible bullies at school that happens
now yeah but would they get credit would
they get the same tax creditors of
people who are committed to their family
yes that's a that's a bad move because
you'd have a lot of piss poor parents in
that situation you still do today if we
said if you are married and have three
kids you don't pay taxes you will you
are more likely to see people stay
together there right now there's a
there's a guy and a lady and they had
three kids already and they're split up
and that's bad for the kids if we said
if you're married you're gonna you're
you know or or how about this single
family household three kids married
meaning the guy and the wind have to
live together with the kids then you get
a tax break wait you're saying they're
not married but they don't have to be
married you have to live together and
have at least three kids and then you're
exempt from Tech income tax wow you can
send your kids to college if you want
you can buy cars you could actually go
on vacation with your kids that's bold
Tim but I mean we need what we do need
to encourage the American family because
right now it is too hard to raise a
family and this should be the not too
hard meeting impossible but it's harder
than it should be and we need to make
this country the friendliest place in
the world to raise a family that's what
that should be the American dream that
should be the focus of public policy
let's talk about the current state of
politics we have the story from the
Daily Mail oh boy dramatic moment
Hunter's lawyer told prosecutors
sweetheart deal was off after judge
eviscerated agreement apparently uh one
of the guys yelled out I think it was um
Biden lawyer Chris Clark said I don't
know what you're trying to accomplish
then we'll rip it up he says you can't
get around that so basically what
happens is they go in Hunter Biden's
gonna supposed to plead guilty to to
this sweetheart deal where it's a slap
on the rest of no jail time the judge
then says well hold on there a minute
this doesn't include any far violations
any potential fire of this plea
agreement just tax evasion right so are
you going to charge him later on the
prosecution says we could Biden's
lawyers are like hey no way no way
the judge then's like what's going on
looks at the deals off they have to go
uh there's a recess they negotiate it
looks like the deal might be back on now
the deal's on hold here's what people
are speculating it seems that Hunter
Biden's lawyers went to these these
prosecutors
and the deal was they will not prosecute
Hunter on anything if he just accepts
these little charges and a slap on the
wrist
it only says on paper these charges but
trust us we're not going to come after
you for anything else but the judge
asked the question if the judge just
rubber stamped it it'd be done and their
back room deal is done but the judge was
like what about pharah well the
prosecution can't lie to question effect
can you charge him or we can they get
mad saying you're you're double crossing
us that's what it seems like it seems
like some shady back room dealing to
throw some red meat at the press and
create a scenario where the media will
say hunter Biden pleads guilty look the
doj is not biased they went for the
president's own son what do you mean
they're going after Trump for political
reasons they went after the president's
son it's totally non-biased but that
back room deal was no good when the
judge spotted it what are the pharah
what's pharah uh four was it foreign
agent registration actually like that
that if you're uh acting on behalf of a
foreign government you have to register
and Hunter Biden was with barisma and
probably a bunch of other countries and
he did not well that's that's odd do you
think you I mean personally if the judge
didn't know this and the ju if they got
any other judge and that judge is like
looks in order to me I guess bang done
wasn't Hunter Biden's computer full of
pornography well yeah yeah so it's just
the whole thing is is obviously very
very sad but it also just shows the
state of the culture right that you know
the president even the first family
right the son is involved in all these
things and I think it's one thing to
talk about tax evasion it sounds like it
happened and he's pleading guilty but
all of these other things you know think
about it we don't I think as a society
we're not hard on porn we think porn's
fine everyone we say everyone most
people use it it's not a big deal it's
legal and so you know Hunter Biden can
do all this stuff and it's crazy and
then oh but he did tax evasion so that's
the bad thing that he did
this is crazy let me read this
and all the stuff about prostitutes and
strippers and it's just it's all all
dark stuff Noriko warned lawyers the
deal was unprecedented and possibly
unconstitutional and could prevent
prosecutors from going after Biden for
other crimes in the future she insisted
she was acting in Hunter's interest by
making sure he knew exactly how much
protection he would or would not get
under the deal but she also unloaded on
it sometimes in personal terms about the
position it put her in as an Arbiter you
keep telling me that I have no role I
shouldn't even be reading this thing she
vented her admonitions force a tense
negotiation if the judge left a
courtroom teams of lawyers faced off and
talks for an hour to the hearing they
had to hash out among themselves what
exactly they had agreed to then sell it
to a judge who was increasingly
skeptical the end result ended in a
politically perilous day delay for
Biden's campaign set to be helmed from
Wilmington in a state blah blah blah
blah blah we get it this is crazy
that the judge was it was so shocked the
judge said the unprecedented nature of
the agreement forced her to step in but
bizarrely she also said she sympathized
with Hunter Mr Biden I know you want to
get this over with she told him at the
end of the three-hour slug Fest which
had the effect of pushing off Hunter's
plea and extending his legal woes into
late Summer and the fall as his father
gears up his presidential re-election
campaign so maybe Roseanne was right
about those military tribunals right
interesting
I I mean I I it still blows my mind that
he's got he's gotten away with as much
as he's gotten away with that that this
is the that he might be able to
still might be able to walk away from
this with it with a plea deal it's it's
I I don't have a whole lot more to add
other than it's just really a a black
pill it's my opinion yeah it's the most
uh Emperor has no clothes thing and that
what that metaphor is is like everyone
can see that the emperor's not wearing
anything but ever but the emperor's
telling people oh I'm wearing a rope so
everyone's like yeah he's wearing a robe
but they all know he's not and then it's
a little kid that's like he's not
wearing any clothes so like we all know
Hunter Biden did this stuff the evidence
is there I mean I I maybe we should say
I don't know but it is very apparent
there's a lot of evidence and uh for Joe
Biden just to be pretending that it's
that it's like not a big deal is the
most insane abuse of power legal
Authority an executive Authority in this
country I've ever seen in my lifetime
I mean I saw George Bush take the world
to war because of weapons of mass
destruction that didn't exist this is
the most disgusting thing I've ever seen
a president do this is robbing our
culture of the truth
it's it is not healthy we need to change
this war is pretty bad um yeah yeah but
it's been happening my whole life this
is like
brainwashing people to be evil that
doesn't make war less bad but I get what
you're saying but this is like it's like
so in plain sight which makes it in my
opinion more disgusting it's like little
kids are like it's okay to lie well it's
interesting because I think you know the
president is such I the liar word is a
good one for him because he professes
this Faith so you know I'm Catholic as
many people know you know I became
Catholic in college and Joe Biden says
like he's Catholic like he ran kind of
on the Catholic Grandpa and this good
man and the uniter I'm this you know man
of integrity and you know separate from
this whole Scandal right he is the most
pro-abortion president the most
pro-sexual deviancy president in
probably our history Maybe Obama was up
there on abortion but he is he's been
more pro-abortion than even Obama so the
White House is a disgrace
and you saw like the topless
um yeah you know uh you know woman or
man who was dressing as a woman and had
you know fake breasts topless there were
three that were topless I mean what a
shame that this has become our white
house and our leadership pro-abortion
pro-sexual deviancy Pro chaos and
unreality you know a man is a woman
woman is a man
it's like the worst thing he's done but
he also sniffs kids and like the
inappropriately touches them and things
like that that is very weird too it
might be the time it's odd the time and
the place because we need I feel like
the Earth is in the most desperate
situation it's ever been in my lifetime
right now and we need real like
straightforward leadership so it's like
coupled with that like what he did yeah
it's guys it's not that bad he just lied
about his son being an abusive
pornography guy or whatever but like or
or a lot he had his son do Billion
Dollar Deals it's like okay it's not as
bad as murdering a hundred thousand
people or murdering a million babies
allowing him million babies a year to be
murdered but we need like George Bush
had the leeway to take us to war in
2003. we don't have the leeway to mess
around right now this is like get your
together or we're done I think he
just needs to be voted out ASAP I mean
there's no there's no I pray for the
president actually I pray for I believe
conversions are possible but it is it is
we are in a severe crisis because of
this not just because of this white
house obviously it's lending to the
problem there's just systemic rot right
now across the country I don't know if
you were going to ask this Phil but what
will happen is if we don't seize moral
Authority on Earth it'll become an
economic forum and the Chinese Communist
party will seize where do we ground our
moral Authority right and that goes back
to the stuff that you know we were
talking about earlier but if we don't
get first things right first human
rights are protected for the most
vulnerable members of a society if we
can't treat the most vulnerable
correctly and if we can't shape you know
men are off with hookers and pornography
and women are on only fans I mean all of
this cultural chaos that were enveloped
in where are we going to have have the
moral authority to go say we're better
than China we're going to go to war with
China we need to fix the rot in our
country and in our culture I feel like
if Ian was dictator of the earth it
would be the most brutal totalitarian
regime ever experienced it would be it
would be one hell of a ride man of
course DMT there's no way oh okay yeah
there's no way I don't think there's any
way to dictate Earth that's the most
insane thing not I mean has a lot of
good intentions it's just we've got it
we gotta form the conscience form our
morality I don't think porn well firstly
I think porn means a lot of things
there's really horrible sex going on on
the internet on YouPorn and things but
then there's also really loving sex
happening on YouPorn like you see the
occasional video two people that really
like each other and like is that a thing
you porn yeah it's youporn.com you know
it's just porn site yeah but if it's if
it's Beauty if it's beautiful loving sex
between two people and it's truly loving
then it should be for just them in the
context of marriage and it's gonna
potentially bring life into the world
because sex is designed to do that and
so they need to be prepared to raise
those children and they shouldn't be
selling it for people to watch on the
internet well if it's really loving sex
I've learned how to have sex from
certain videos
like different positions different
different
um rhythms like and and that's like was
help helpful for me in the long run so
if so I don't think it's all evil and
like we should just never watch Ever sex
I don't personally well I think it
that's an interesting question because I
think if for example I think if you're
in a a marriage and you are wanting to
love your spouse better I think it's
absolutely appropriate to learn more
about sex so that you can learn how to
have the best sex with your spouse and
the best way to do that is with your
spouse right that's what I think
um not by watching other people have sex
well that I mean if you sometimes if
people are in an insulated environment
they just repeat the same thing over and
over and over again that's all they know
because they don't know there's other
methodologies the problem with watching
people have sex is typically people do
that so that they can have sexual
gratification from that yeah it's not
it's not like a class right I agree with
that because for orgasms pornography for
orgasm typically if you let your mind
think of the person on the video that's
like demoralizing but if you watch the
porn and then think about your
girlfriend
that's like a healthy I found it feels a
lot healthier and I use the technique on
the girlfriend
well I would say that sex is for two
people who have committed each other to
each other for life and that they're in
that commitment they're willing to bring
children into the world because sex
brings life even when you use
contraception it fails 50 of the people
who have abortions were using
contraception so contraception is not
some fail safe it fails you know it
doesn't always work and so marriage is
the beautiful solution to all of this
and in a marriage I think you can
definitely you know maybe uh study about
how do we have sex with each other
better but I don't think pornography has
any role in that I've heard people say
well we watch porn as a couple in order
to have a stronger more loving
relationship and I don't think that
really works in the real world one of
the top reasons for divorce is
pornography I wonder if the end result
second top reason listed for why people
divorce is pornography at the end of the
day your sexually visualizing someone
who's not your spouse I wonder you
should Reserve that for just results
because that's your one flesh you've
committed to just like the left upload
their brains to computers and then
humans
the conservative humans just stay and
have families and live normal
traditional human lives do you think oh
what do you say though well I mean to
Tim's Point I've I've mentioned before I
think at some point there's going to be
like actual protection for people that
are not augmented like the way that we
have carved out space for the Amish in
in the United States how they don't have
to follow the same laws that everyone
else says there will be people that are
going to say I'm not going to get any
kind of augmentation or whatever and
there's going to be people that are
going to be augmented that are going to
have to protect them from other people
that are augmented like real sci-fi kind
of and they're like but here's the
thing I mean the whole thing about well
the traditional people will go to the
traditional things and then everyone
else will go crazy I think all people we
have the same human nature and so we
have a lot of shared struggles right and
then bad ideology can make us do bad
behaviors that ultimately can warp our
Natures but I think all people are
called to the same goodness and so I
would say liberal on the left should get
married too they should have children
too they should be faithful too they
should be against pornography and
abortion and all these things too and I
think some are I mean I know for example
I know some more progressives entering
the pro-life movement and a lot of them
doing amazing work in the public
movement and many of them are as they're
learning about sex and life and
bioethics many of them are becoming not
just pro-life but they're becoming okay
I'm pro-marriage I'm Pro these more
Traditional Values but I can still maybe
have more left-leaning beliefs on maybe
immigration or these other topics but
they're very passionate about marriage
now as well as life and as you know what
are seen as the more traditional value
so I think their Traditional Values are
not just for conservatives if they're if
it's true if it's morality it should be
for everybody like I do think men and
women are different testosterone I just
started working out like a week two
weeks ago and my testosterone's been out
of control like my sex drive has been
like a rocket and I important
information yeah I thank you Tim and uh
I think if there's like absolute
conversation tonight especially
considering is killing me I'm sitting
here dying especially you're talking
about babies I know I know but Ian's
talking about fairly intimate details
about his to the top history oh
continues but it feels like absolutely
I'm loving it like um if you were to say
what like I don't know are you
suggesting like delete all the porn
sites prevent anyone from being able to
see it ever kind of yes I think we
should ban pornography and I also think
that we should as a society move towards
and we should set up say hey monogamy is
awesome we should celebrate monogamy
marriage and we also I think should
encourage people to not be sexually
active until they're married one of the
things that I I hear you talking about
encouraging but I feel like you want to
get rid of things so you're talking
about legislation well definitely porn
and abortion the legislation see that
that's where I have especially abortion
I mean I
definitely get your point on abortion
I've been feeling it all night so and
and because if if we believe they're
human beings or agree that they're human
beings and we this is the pro-life case
just boil down it is always wrong to
intentionally kill an innocent human
most people agree with that yes we're at
War abortion well in that case it's
still wrong because under just War
Theory you're not supposed to Target
civilians right sometimes they're die
accidentally but you can't intentionally
Target the civilian right enemy commands
are not innocent and are not innocent
yeah but exactly Dresden because they
were running products through the city
and there can be war crimes there can be
war crimes so that but the idea of a
crime within War means it's always wrong
to intentionally kill an innocent person
an innocent human abortion intentionally
kills an innocent human therefore
abortion is always wrong and that means
not only should we not have abortions
but we should ban abortions because
these are human beings that deserve
equal protection under the law the 14th
Amendment says that we have equal
protection we should have equal
protection under the law all persons and
no state has the right to deprive life
of any person without due process and
the only there's no due process for The
Unborn Child the pro-abortion crowd has
is just to say that babies aren't alive
right which is no I mean deep down I
think most people know that
if it wasn't alive the child wasn't
alive you wouldn't need to kill them I
asked him when does he think Life Begins
and he said sometime after birth a few
months after birth something like that I
think he said yeah okay that's that's
the exact same argument that uh the
people that would would argue for
post-birth abortions make things these
are the kind of people that like torture
squirrels alive I can't think I would
argue for when it becomes a human not
necessarily I do believe it's living
tissue and then it becomes a human over
time but but I want to get back to porn
you you want to say every day
um if we banned it it feels like this
forced abstinence mentality that I've
been told my whole life doesn't work
like if you tell a kid don't have sex
they just go off and get pregnant when
they're 15 because they don't have any
sexual education sure and sort of
prevent it oh anyway you know what I
mean well there's a multi-billion dollar
pornography industry right and so we can
penalize that to say no you can't be
because there's a lot of sex trafficking
that happens in it a lot of children
that are I mean the harms associated
with the creation of porn are so
numerous children caught up in it I mean
child pornography a child assault
material has been proliferating online
once you start talking about once you
start talking about like child
pornography now you're talking about a
different topic because I understand
that there are correlations in there
there are links but the the topic that
that we're discussing if we're talking
about adult entertainment that's adult
stuff because there's no one at this
table is is in any way gonna gonna be
Pro child uh you know child rape or
anything which is all it is so the the
the associations with adult movies and
then with with child rape I I think
they're they're far enough different
where we can at least say hey
the adult industry doesn't lead to child
rape child rape happens let's jump to
this story the reality is with the
prolific proliferation of pornography in
general it creates sexual appetites and
addictions that need to be continually
stimulated with going down this Rabbit
Hole more and more violent or rape
centered pornography let's move on so
it's all interconnected unfortunately
because it's all I think ultimately
abusive this next story is also
connected we have a story from
timcast.com Kevin Spacey acquitted of
sexual assault charges in London there's
a lot for a lot for me to process after
what has just happened today Spacey said
he was found not guilty of the nine
sexual assault charges filed against him
in the United Kingdom and the
interesting thing I'm seeing from the
story is that there are a lot of people
I'm saying it's split online they're
saying we know he's guilty anyway and
there are other people saying this
proves the metoo moral Panic was
complete BS so what do you think is
Kevin Spacey guilty no matter what even
if the court found him not guilty
because I think there was one report
that he was on he was witnessed being
like on one of the planes with Epstein
or something like that or was he falsely
accused because of me too woke victim
culture my first thought is that he's
innocent until he's proven guilty and if
he wasn't proven guilty he's innocent
that's just the way legal system works
apparently this was in the UK it doesn't
work like that in the UK I don't know I
don't know enough about the um about the
accusations against him so it's kind of
hard to say he grabbed a bunch of dudes
junk
I mean that's horrible if that's if that
is true should not have happened and
it's wrong so I I think it's hard it's
hard to kind of SP I I wouldn't
speculate myself just because I don't I
didn't I haven't studied the allegations
against him I do think that just because
something doesn't turn up a guilty
verdict in a court of law doesn't mean
the person's automatically innocent of
course they're innocent in terms of the
law but that doesn't mean in society
that's a good person to hang out with
necessarily so I think it depends on
what were the allegations and I'd have
to
study them to make any kind of opinion
that's a good point I'm not saying he
didn't do it it's different he's just
legally innocent right of course and
that's right
the court of law matters a lot I think
some of the people accuse him died right
I've heard that something like that
I do think this is part you know back to
what you were saying you know I think
you were kind of speaking to
um maybe a concern about
authoritarianism
I'm very very anti-government I I see it
I think there's a lot of wisdom to being
wary of a government getting too big and
too powerful so I think there's a lot of
wisdom to that but I'm speaking more
when I talk about you know sexual ethics
less about the government imposing
exactly whether or not you make sexual
mistakes I don't think that's even
possible right it's one thing to ban
pornographers from selling porn it's
another thing to you know have a camera
in every house to see are you looking at
porn that I would never say is the right
thing to do that's of abuse in and of
itself but I think the question that I'm
the more speaking to is what's the right
way for us to behave in a society what's
healthiest what's best what's the moral
path and you know the whole Kevin this
whole Kevin Spacey story unfortunately
whether or not he is the abuser you know
it's inconclusive it seems from just
this headline we don't know I mean the
court found him you know not guilty I
haven't studied that's what I'm saying
he's innocent in this case obviously
with the court but there is a I would
just say all around Society there is
chaos in male female relationships I
think we all agree with that people are
and there was a Pew research that came
out saying that the large majority of
people are unhappy with dating most
think dating is worse today than it's
ever been
um you know people you know a lot of
women feel objectified and then they're
objectifying themselves they're normally
fans a lot of men feel like there's no
women to date that are good anymore so
there's total chaos and I would argue
that's because we've forgotten first
principles about the moral way to treat
each other that sex belongs within
marriage that sex can bring life into
the world so you should be prepared for
that and take responsibility for that
when we forget these first principles
then we open the door to all this chaos
and I think we're living the fruit of
the sexual Revolution which basically
uprooted all sexual mores and said as
long as there's consent you're good to
go whatever and I think that's brought a
lot of unhappiness and Brokenness today
I think that there's a lot of a lot of
Truth to the to your point there uh the
the role the gender roles the fact that
men and women don't have uh the clear
distinction as to what is a man's role
and what is a woman's role in
relationships nowadays I think is is
something that you're seeing the effects
like you said you're seeing the effects
in society I think you've got you've got
a lot and social uh socialization was a
huge element of marriage as well for
women who were mostly hanging out with
other women they want to have husband
they can brag about to their friends and
they also want a good husband and men
not only want a good wife but they want
someone that they can be proud of and
both the man and woman are like I feel
really good when people see who I'm with
well marriage is such a beautiful
institution and as a Catholic it's a
Sacrament you know it's such a beautiful
thing because it not only can bring new
life into the world and I think that is
the primary purpose of marriage is the
ability to bring life and some people
maybe are infertile with most people
they get that beautiful opportunity but
it also brings Harmony between the Sexes
where we're working in this beautiful
way in harmony together and we're a lot
we've lost Harmony in a lot of ways in
our culture like psychically deadened to
the harmony of nature
yeah I don't know why I think it's
dietary personally it could be a lot of
stuff social media is messing people up
staring at computer screens for more
than two hours a day I think if there's
one thing that you could do to change
that I think getting rid of no fault
divorce would have a massive massive
impact on uh on American society I think
that like the Knowles I think it was
Michael Knowles that said like if like
the way that him and his wife were
saying there will never be a divorce
because if there is a divorce whoever
proposes the divorce gives up everything
or something like that if the uh yeah
whoever proposes the divorce should be
saying look I'm giving I'll give up
everything not like I want a divorce and
I'm getting half of the that's the
prenup it just says anybody who proposes
a divorce
removes All rights to any claims and any
property and et cetera et cetera unless
I mean that might be good abuse or like
you know infidelity or something so one
of the old rules of that you could get a
divorce like I just I just think abolish
no fault doors yeah I think that I I
think that getting rid of no fault
divorce would be because it would be a
good thing because nowadays people do
look at at marriage like I'm actually
serious yeah but or because I think
there are a lot I think that men might
think like that I don't think women
think of things like that I think that
they want to say they well they like the
unmarried kind of like Mystique that
goes with it um more than men would but
at the same at the same time there are
plenty of people that would get married
just for a tax crediting after last year
after Roe v Wade was overturned there
was all of these articles and we just
did a actually a satirical video at live
action about these articles but they
were from like Vox and these different
news companies about all these people
said my sex life is going to change
forever because Roe was overturned now
I'm gonna have to be really careful
about who I am wasn't it really funny
how the it was so it just left us women
were like we're gonna boycott sex right
and then concertos were like no wait
don't I mean but right but it just shows
like I mean first of all it is a fact
that abortion is backup contraception
and even the people who claim contrast
options stops abortions they know that
and they're lying the contraception only
increases the abortion rate ultimately
because it gives people this false sense
of security that oh I'm going to have
sex and you know I'm not ready for being
a parent I'm not even married I'm gonna
have sex oops I get pregnant okay well
abortion's my backup contraception
that's the way it's operating that's why
we have 2500 abortions a day in this
country I would say more important even
than you know your your case for
abolishing no fault divorce if we
abolished abortion which is killing
people then it would change sexual
ethics and it already is changing sexual
Ethics in places where even from the
people who say yeah changing my sexual
behavior places where abortion is
illegal my concern though is if people
do it in back alleys with the most
gruesome methodologies if we don't
change the culture's mentality before we
legislate that they can't do it anymore
they've got to do both because the law
is the teacher so that you know a lot of
women and a lot of men who are
pressuring for abortions if abortion's
not readily accessible they they many of
them don't have abortion so the law does
influence your behavior we know that
with seat belts you know when there's a
lot of wear a seat belt you wear the
seat belt back in the 80s now when I
think wore seat belts because there was
no law so the law was wrong
I'm from New Hampshire and we don't have
seat belt laws up there but I wear my
seatbelt we're in Virginia Safety First
yeah but but bottom line is the law does
matter but I agree with you I think
you're making a good point that the
culture matters a ton too and that's
where you know talking about this stuff
is so important and having open
conversations because I think a lot of
people I think ultimately we want love
you know like sex at the end yes you
know there's sexual gratification but
most people today I think deep down
people in general they want love they
want a loving relationship you know that
girl of your dreams that man of your
dreams they're not just looking for an
orgasm they're looking at the end of the
day for love and people who just hook up
ultimately feel empty in the end so
talking about how do we actually achieve
that well if you start putting sex back
into marriage and getting to know each
other before sleeping together like
really get to know each other really
understand is this someone I share
values with what I want to raise a
family with you know that would do so
much to improve relationships but how
what do you think about no fault divorce
are you would you be open to getting rid
of it you know what I'm torn because
first of all I would have to study a lot
more what the you know what the nuances
might be because I do think we have an
epidemic of abuse today
we do have a ton of abuse but that's not
nothing to do with no fault divorce if I
I agree abusing their spouse they can
get a divorce I I agree it's not caused
by no fault divorce I agree with that no
no but when abuse is Fault meaning I
understand abolish no fault divorce and
abuse occurs you get a divorce that it's
true in theory right but in practice
it's very tricky because in practice
proving abuse when it's he said she said
in a court of law can be very difficult
so I'm not saying we shouldn't get rid
of no fault divorce I'm very much uh
open to that because I do think we have
a divorce problem and we're just
divorcing for stupid reasons and I think
that's bad I think we're we're just I
want to follow my my dreams we weren't
compatible anymore and then there's
these beautiful children who are left in
the chaos of that and then we pretend
this there's no marriage
that's kind of how I felt like I got
burned in the 20s there's no commitment
yeah if at any point you can just sign a
paper and it ceases to exist yeah
I mean I I agree that it's way too easy
to get to get in a divorce I agree with
that so I think there's maybe varying
degrees of what you mean by abolishing
no fault divorce but I agree that it's
too easy to divorce and too many people
do it too quickly absolutely that's
that's it's that simple well even more
importantly than even more importantly
than don't get married if you're just
going to quit on the marriage because I
think that's absolutely right I think we
also should be saying and this is very
controversial because this is not the
way people think today don't have sex if
you're not married and people you know a
lot of people are like well you know I
remember telling I think it was tough I
don't think you're gonna win that one
because people will get married just to
have sex that's not a good thing either
well that too but I think you're you're
going to find
people are gonna bang you can't stop
them I mean people are always going to
do a lot of things right and but I think
Barney but I think it's more I do think
it's possible to have self-control I
think it is I think it's possible to
have a sexual attraction for someone and
not hook up with them but but that's
that's you right like the reason these
things exist is because humans do these
things that's it if it were a symbol to
say like people should have self-control
these things wouldn't exist they'd have
self-control but they don't want to they
they that that's why I brought up the
point about liberals ultimately just
downloading their brain their brains
into computers because they're chasing
carnal pleasure they don't care about
anything else they don't care for the
future they care about short-term
gratification that's it I do think you
can work on your behavior so I know
an alcoholic I don't drink anymore but
like you you you can't get someone
that's doing something whether it's
detrimental to themselves or not you
can't get them to do to change Behavior
unless they want to so like the the
fundamental thing that you're talking
about of oh we need to get people to
change their behavior I get it but
you're dealing with people that have a
totally different philosophical point of
view from you and and don't even start
with they're repeat like this this is
something that I've I've had to come to
terms within the past five or ten years
or so but there are people out there
that whose starting principles are so
different they don't even believe that
you can engage in a conversation
honestly with another person they
believe it's all power games so the idea
that you can get people hey you know you
just shouldn't have sex when you're
talking to people that are atheists or
people that are that are agnostic and
stuff I don't think that that's an
actual like yeah it's it's it's it's
it's it's starting from a place it's a
it's a non-starter I guess so I talk to
a lot of young people Jen's ears who
feel and Millennials you know over the
years back when they were younger but
who feel like if they didn't have sex
they were the weirdo that if they were
the Virgin they were the weirdo it's
like the you know the 40 year old virgin
movie you know like the weirdo right the
weirdo but I think that's the problem
right so it's one thing where people
make their own decisions right we can't
control what people do I agree with you
100 but I do think we can change the
narrative on this I don't think that
it's peer pressure I think that it comes
from inside of people like I think the
the urges that we have the urge to eat
isn't because homie told you that
steak's real good over and over and over
it's because you have an urge to eat and
actually I did not eat until my friend
was like I was like
and that's one of the urges but if
there's a lot of societal forces like
you know we all love ice cream at least
I'm gonna guess you all like I love it
but that's it you haven't eaten in a
long time because you have these ideals
and these this view now that maybe if I
eat too much ice cream it will make me
sick right and so I think and you know
what's good for my body right what is
the right thing to do for my body so
similarly I would argue we're not
talking enough about the harm of sex
before outside of marriage we're just
saying well everyone's going to do it
anyways give them a condom and it's
great that's not the right approach the
right approach and said to say you have
we have we can practice discipline we
can practice self-control people are
happier and they stay together longer
when they don't have sex before marriage
and don't shack up before marriage the
social data proves that but is it so we
should be talking about it they have
commercials for medication and it's this
big fat guy and he eats a big old greasy
pepperoni pizza and then goes oh and
it's like wanna eat the food you love
and then he pops a pill and he smiles
and eats the pizza again and I'm like
stop you're kid I agree this is America
and we have a cultural sickness I said
earlier our culture is dead I agree with
you instant gratification and
meaningfulness not good but you know I I
do think there's a political conundrum
in a group of people desperate to
sterilize and and remove themselves from
the gene pool
who are also eating garbage celebrating
having horbid uh uh uh I'm sorry morbid
obesity and then you have conservatives
desperately trying to keep them voting
yeah and so like that's never going to
resolve itself if what I'm saying about
you know sex and it being designed for
within marriage because sex bonds you
dramatically to another person and it
can create new life which are two things
for marriage Lifelong Love and
responsibility and then children right
that family project together and so yeah
of course if someone disagrees it's like
I disagree with this girl I'm not going
to do that they're free to do what they
want to do in the end right but what I'm
trying to say is why don't we have more
conversations about the beauty of what
we're aiming for like that beautiful
image of the couple that's married 50
years and they're holding hands on the
Park Bench right and they were their
first lover you know they were virgins
when they got married and they committed
to that I mean it takes a convention I'm
not saying it's easy exactly it's
culture so we can do our part in
creating culture and not saying like
people are doomed to just hook up and
sleep together and be promiscuous no
one's doomed to promise Judy no one's
doing you gotta go to super chats you
said that people that don't and we will
go to super chess really fast uh that uh
people that are don't have sex before
marriage tend to be happier and have a
longer relationship but is it possible
that happier people don't have sex
before marriage
it's an interesting meaning they they
have other values that they are
cherishing and learning about each other
intellectually spiritually
Etc is that kind of what you're saying I
think they'll study measure relative
happiness from point A to point B so
that is from the point of marriage Ten
Years Later how would you write your
happiness here how would you rate your
happiness here because happiness is
always relative we know there's less we
know there's less STIs unplanned
pregnancy and we know there's less
divorce with less sexual partners there
are they they uh one of my favorite
studies they found that a paraplegic one
year after their accident and a lottery
Wing winner one year after winning right
the same levels of happiness oh my gosh
so it's it's all relative to to where
you are in life you know I've been to
some slums in foreign countries these
people are are as happy as happy can be
with their family so when you look at
that and you look at the data people who
are they've had no other sexual partners
before marriage say I'm very happy 10
years later I'm very happy people who
had multiple partners say I I'm very
happy I'm completely unhappy we got
divorced but it's not just a feeling
whether or reporting happiness that's
also behavior and
it is a fact that people who cohabitate
before marriage are more likely to
divorce than people who don't we're
going to go to super chats but one final
most people don't know cohabitation is
illegal in West Virginia interesting but
most people are told cohabitate is good
because it'll help you get to know each
other and try it on before you marry to
avoid divorce that's the cultural
narrative today and that's actually not
true it's better to not cohabitate and
practice the sexual morality to each
other to really get to know each other
on a spiritual and intellectual level
get to understand each other's families
backgrounds and then hey is this a life
project partner that I'm a committed for
life to raise a family with yes okay now
I'm going to marry and pledge myself to
you publicly now we'll share each
other's bodies we're gonna go to Super
Chat a beautiful idea so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends and become a
member by going to timcast.com and
clicking join us and we're gonna have a
members only show over at timcast.com at
about 10 pm where you as members can
actually call into the show if you sign
up for at least 25 bucks a month or
you've been a member for at least six
months you can submit questions and even
call into the show all right I'm not
your buddy guy says I think this aliens
nonsense is twofold a to prevent war
with China hey we got a cool space Tech
and B to distract from how horrible the
state is interesting military Flex all
right what do we got Raymond g Stanley
Jr says Tim did you see the viral video
of our best Eternal man Mitch McConnell
glitching out hmm him Biden Feinstein
fetterman and many more we are a broken
Nation Trump needs to be our last 70
plus leader sounds like he was sitting
on the show with us tonight well this
was at eight o'clock that's why you were
reading our minds man before we got into
it
what is this uh kritik says Whitmer
signed into law to ban conversion
therapy today would love a discussion on
this thank you for your work uh it's
really it's really it's for lgbtq youth
it's really weird that a uh a program
that you choose to do
is banned right they're not mercilessly
beating children over here in the state
of California if you counsel someone
with unwanted same-sex attraction and
there are youth and you're counseling
them to deal with their unwanted
same-sex attraction you can get in
trouble with the law that's how far gone
we are because of the mythology around
conversion therapies that are so evil
yes have there been some evil conversion
therapies yes but most counselors who
are I think seeing this the correct way
understand that same-sex attraction a
lot of it is connected to traumas issues
in your past how you developed your
relationship with your mother your
father and those things need to be
explored especially when that person is
saying what is this with me I don't
understand the way that I am and the
fact that we don't even have those
conversations we're not even allowed to
have those conversations I think is
horrible it's it's so I was just
interviewing a woman who was living in a
lesbian relationship like a I think she
was married or she was in a long-term
relationship and she ended up rejecting
that because she said that was what I
was told was going to make me happy and
in the end but at the end of the day she
said my identity is in God you know
she's a Christian but it also is
realizing that I'm not designed to have
sex with a woman that's not my identity
that's not what I'm designed for so I
think we need to hear more of those
voices but again that's like faux pas
today you're not allowed to talk about
that and I think that's a problem and it
hurts a lot of people
1985 says Tim please help Ohio Dems are
trying to get no limit abortion in the
state constitution August 8th we are
having a special election to change the
bar to pass amendments from 51 to 60.
vote Yes on issue one on the 8th if
you're in Ohio
well all right I mean there's a lot of
ballot initiatives being pushed by the
pro-abortion side to permit abortion
through all nine months for any reason
it just happened in California we passed
proposition one horrible in Colorado so
we've got to fight we've definitely got
to fight that Oklahoma check out
liveaction.org and we'll help quickly
for the fight Oklahoma Bandit and
Colorado has it unlimited which means
these two states would share a border
are going to be a potential hot seat for
serious conflict a woman in Oklahoma
will flee to Colorado the father is
going to say hey she's fleeing the state
to commit a crime the state's going to
have no authority to go to the state
federal government won't intervene and
uh I think or will intervene who knows
geez yeah or or the guy will get a posse
because the federal government yeah
exactly if Government doesn't intervene
in that situation for for to stop it or
to allow it someone else is it's like
you can't oh gosh
yeah well that's what happens when we
don't protect constitutional rights for
all and just some states are doing it
and other states are allowed to encroach
on them I mean the fact that in
California if you're conceived in
California you can be killed until you
know weeks before days before birth did
you hear us hear the story of the
surrogate in California I don't think
yeah where the the guys wanted the sir
the baby terminated but so two men who
have no business trying to adopt or
create a child two men got together they
hired a surrogate they they hired an egg
donor they created these babies in in
vitro uh through IVF and then they
implanted this little beautiful baby boy
and this woman they you know got a
surrogate and she gets cancer she gets
breast cancer and she is gonna need
treatment and the baby is about 24 25
weeks old so old enough to survive you
can survive as young as 21 21 weeks six
days five days I think is the earliest
surviving little boy little girl and
what did the dads say the dads are not
even dads these men who purchase this
life now destroy it and she said well
let me let me give birth to it and let
it let if the adopted I'll adopt him
this little boy we don't want our DNA
out there one of the dudes and so what
happened they delivered this beautiful
little boy 25 weeks old and left him to
die ultimately and this was all done
legally in the state of California where
abortions legal through all nine months
why did she let it happen
she shouldn't have she's responsible too
in my opinion I think surrogates I think
women who give their bodies you know I
can see the some good intentions in it
for some people saying I'm trying to
help this family I think it was all
wrong it should all be stopped and women
shouldn't be have any part in selling
their wombs and then you open the door
to these horrible human rights abuses
like this little this little boy that
was killed brought into existence and
then killed
all right let's read let's read some
more
Robert Romano says they need not be
Interstellar they could be nearby we're
not alone or is it to convince Russia we
have invulnerable alien Tech but it's
fake that's what I'm saying they could
be reptilians you know like this the
ship could be from the center of the
earth that came out of the hole in the
North Pole especially now the ice caps
are melting and the lizard people could
be coming up that's why crashing a
River of blood and Antarctica my one of
my favorite conspiracy theories is that
well in the age of dinosaurs before the
meteor struck the Earth and wiped
everything out there was a species of
dinosaur that was cave dwelling and uh
you know got their resources and food
through cave Moss or something like that
I don't think any of this made sense but
I was reading this it's really funny and
it's like they survived the uh the
meteor strike and then evolved super
intelligence but live underground and
then I love this too because it
connected it with a Denver Airport you
know like the Denver Airport has like
eight sub-levels which connects to a
network of underground cities inhabited
by dinosaur people and I was like was
that a TV show like Land of the Lost or
something where they go into the Earth
and then they're in this alternate
reality or something dude Journey to the
Center of the Earth it's an old Jules
Verne book which is a great book
that's a different story yeah it is a
different story yeah I never saw Land of
the Lost Denver Airport's a terrible
airport yeah it could be uh I was just
there international and I'm sorry uh
it could be within us without us it
takes forever like um a vibration in
space time that's being hype
concentrated by like spiritual Force
that could be what's the aliens are
ghostgate says aliens are Jesus and the
angels the Antichrist is A.I and they'll
be a parent in early 2027. Jesus returns
in mid-september
2030. if Jesus doesn't return to destroy
the AI the only I think the only way
Christ will return is if it returns
within you
and all of us together at once no but I
think I think Christians believe that
he's like actually coming back right
yeah he is
um he is coming back I think the alien
stuff in some to some degree is a big
distraction to the Frankenstein style
experiments we're doing on human beings
in Laboratories not just in places like
China but in the United States it's like
putting them in craft I mean who knows
if that what babazar saw was it wasn't
okay all the experimentation we're doing
on these little tiny babies were
bringing into existence just to
experiment on them and kill them it is
sick and I think no one's talking about
it there's very few headlines about it
right it's not making your Twitter feed
most of the time would you endorse going
to war with China to stop China from
doing experiments like that
it's an interesting question because
China's gonna
I think that I think that the the moral
problem of just going to war with the
country and all of the the evils
associated with war you know there's a
lot of evils happening in a lot of
countries right but we don't go invade
them and well some people say we do we
do that to some degree in some countries
right
um and there's a lot of debate about
that is that right that we do that but I
would say generally speaking
um we should first fix our own house and
we're doing evil stuff in the United
States it's not just happening in China
you know our abortion rate is one of the
highest in the world 2 500 children are
killed every day here we're
experimenting them on them in our Labs
we're creating them like the little boy
in California and then killing them at
25 weeks old born alive left to die
because he did he wasn't wanted by his
his dad you know the whole thing is is
sick so I would say let's address that
and then we can worry about China Noah
Sanders says Tim if you have too many
chickens you should hold a livestock
auction for your Elite members get rid
of chickens make some money and content
and have a community building event all
in one that's actually a really good
idea episode exactly if we can legally
do it we have like Ian is basically
auctioning off the citizens how fast can
you talk no no no loves this you just
double the speed over and over again and
a few of the of the crew will go into
cast go into chicken City and negotiate
with Roberto Jr for this of his
prisoners and then he you know goes and
sells them cast negotiating with
terrorists yeah Ian's like we have so
much gold foreign
lately with this protein buff but if
it's just a lot how many eggs do you eat
a day
I don't eat that many okay who eats them
because there's like they were like well
people are eating them but we have 30 30
cartons of eggs just sitting there yeah
they're gonna go bad if they don't get
eaten but they're good for a long time
they last a lot a couple weeks to a
month maybe reasonably but you know wash
them they go bad faster yeah you don't
wash them but uh uh we make stuff maybe
we'll just have a big frittata thing on
Friday no she did it tomorrow I like
that it's a frittata not an omelette I
like that oh we're gonna or we could do
like a quiche why don't we do like a
massive delicious like mushrooms in one
area of the quiche green pepper in
another area then you can have them like
overlapping extra circles we can on the
table tomato we just make a big thing a
big mound of flour and you make a hole
and we we put all the eggs in it and
then we you know make pasta that sounds
good actually I do need to eat more
flour now so that could be cool I don't
know if I need it but it's good carbs
yeah but we got too many eggs but
actually it would be a good idea because
um we have too many chickens we have too
many they make more of themselves listen
what you could do is you could give the
eggs away
we could we we could ship the eggs to
people who want to incubate them and
then have their own chicken City strain
but you know we got a bunch of just
random backyard chickens and they're all
hooking up and you know mutating and
stuff
doing weird chicken things space yeah
donate an egg drive you could donate
them a lot of people would love some
farm fresh eggs from I think it would be
cool
we'll go somewhere and we'll just like
set up a little stage or whatever I'm
gonna practice the fast talking yeah
I would love to hear he's doing the
chicken auction yeah I would love it
we're working on the uh the Casper uh
commercials I'm really excited for
because Roberto Jr is going to be in it
who's Roberto Jr he's the rooster he's
the son of the original rooster Roberto
he's the son of Roberto obviously right
so do the hens have names too or just
Roberto oh they do yeah yeah well the
original ones I know all their names but
then um there's a whole bunch more that
they all have they all have names but uh
do you remember all of your chickens
names Tim I did not name them I named
the original Seven the original six
actually they're actually we we guests
get to name a chicken uh no the the
chicken City audience named them oh okay
so they just culturally decide and so
there's a Wiki for it there's a Wiki
chicken City Wiki where people will talk
about the lore of the city and like uh
what happened with Roberto Roberto uh uh
was was sent to the penal colony at
cocktown for sexual assault I think yeah
he ripped her back up pretty bad man
yeah he was he was he was so he was the
girl's too hard and so he got shipped
away and then Roberto Jr Roberto Jr
super chill he's very nice I like him so
Roberto has was from a farm and so he
doesn't like people you know he's okay
but he's kicked me a couple times and
Roberto Jr was hatched right in front of
me and my girlfriend Allison and so he's
super chill and likes people he's like
you can walk up he'll just look at you
and then go back
[Applause]
it's awesome
yes it is he's right outside let's read
it it is awesome my pet chicken when I
was a little girl died a very
traumatic death so I have a soft spot
for chicken I love them all right leguma
says aliens are real Biden's pyramid
ship is on the way when it arrives he
will convene a press conference his eyes
will shine bright and his voice will get
demonic his gibberish will turn out to
be go wild he will shout
kefkara in the camera and launch his
death gliders at Mar-A-Lago
it turns out all the things he was
saying were actually secret codes being
sent to the the alien planet the aliens
are going to land and he's going to look
at them and they're going to be like
they're gonna say trinomana pressure
and then we're gonna be like what what
what and then they're gonna explain that
the true form was showing near the end
of your journey those are the three
phrases that must be uttered to summon
the the the the aliens to Earth that's
funny so he's cracking his human visit
just cracking in these alien languages
coming out
well no it's like that's his mission
there like you have to say this code
word and then once all three code words
are admitted in in this order it you're
signaling The Invasion oh okay he can't
just do it all at once because it'd be
too weird if he said Trinity pressure
beta kef care next I'll wrestling people
would be like whoa what was that yeah
I'm different but he does one mutterance
and then another and here and there and
people are just like ah silly Joe
gibbern again they were like first
plagiarize your official presidential
campaign to acknowledge that you are on
the mission so we did that in 1988.
kurtalinga says Tim Tim you kind of
dropped the ball by not calling your
pumpkin spice Brew hocus bocus with a
ghost Kitty on the label but that's like
a Halloween thing right so we're doing
an espresso espresso roast called focus
with Mr bocus and then Mr bocus's
pumpkin spice experience was just
because it's a funny name
but we're gonna have year-round pumpkin
spice I don't know if that ruins it for
people I like it yeah it does make me
sad when pumpkin spice leaves the market
it's only here for like two months why
it's the supply and demand thing they
want to make it special but it shouldn't
be special all day long it would be
special all year long to me anyway
bad guacamole says in my opinion here's
a real life example of possible Nephilim
DNA search Ursula and Sabina Erickson
Madness in the fast lane it's very hard
to look at these ladies as human after
watching I don't know about all that
you know I I I I think I was saying
porphyria or whatever it's just like
this Affliction and that's where the
vampire myth comes from they saw a guy
who was like you know bony and he had
like his his gums were receding and
they're like it's a vampire and it's
just like some poor dude who's got a
genetic disorder that's what I'm talking
about yeah
yep yep Bing Bong hell says disappointed
by Tim's uh lack knowledge of the
history of the U.S gov cover-up of UFOs
going back to the 70s watch the
phenomenon if you want to know more X
Operation Blue Book
balmstrom a Air Force Base I'm fighting
to say he's here do it
will not be done people will clip it uh
dude I don't believe the alien stuff
it's just you know what happened with
Roswell
something they were working on crashed
and they were like we can't let them
figure out what it is just say it's
aliens and then they were like oh no now
they think there's aliens say it's not
aliens what are you doing and something
like that that sounds reasonable to me I
I think that we are I do think that it
is possible to have feeling there to be
aliens and I don't think that
contradicts in any way being Catholic or
being Christian demons
yeah well even if there are actual like
another life form another creature that
was created on another planet and it
does it's not included in the Genesis
story I think that doesn't mean the
Dennis's story isn't true and that
everything we believe to do isn't true
yeah God said but the thing is you can
be a Christian and believe in aliens
that's what I'm saying I believe that
it's possible that they exist but I
agree with you I'm not I don't really
buy it I think it's a there's plenty of
stuff to worry about already here I like
that in American Dad they did an episode
where you know people are being uh
raptured or whatever and uh the the
alien what Roger he's like he's like I
want to go and then Jesus is like one of
my dad's side projects but it's like the
aliens aren't welcome in God's kingdom
because they're just like not part of it
God created Man In His Image that's like
our dogs also like bipedal
um symmetrical kind of thing like two of
you ever so maybe there are other
creatures on Earth
it is the The Body Matters a lot but
it's the soul too so our ability to love
our ability to reason our mind our soul
is what is Godlike about us do dogs go
heaven
like I don't I think could I have no
problem with the dog going down person
but oh Sheamus says they don't I mean I
think there could be dogs in heaven no
Sheamus said they all go to hell
how could you it'll burn why is he is
Sheamus a cat person or something no I'm
kidding okay
James is a spoon person yeah but uh he
said uh behalf of him but I'm pretty
sure he says animals don't go to heaven
you know it's interesting I I think that
heaven is you know your the beatific
Vision so you're in this perfect
communion with God who loves you and you
love God and you're just glorifying him
in this Perfection for eternity I also
think that we God knows how to make good
things for humans we're still human in
heaven right it's not like we change our
nature we're still human and so I would
argue that it is possible that
everything we enjoy on earth like food
or our loving relationship with our cat
or dog we're gonna have perfection in
heaven so will there be some experience
of that in heaven maybe I mean we have
the ultimate which is God and we're
totally satisfied with God but as an
aspect of that what we enjoy in animals
and in food and all these other things I
just I'm just saying it's going to be
perfect and having an amazing and blow
your mind so
it doesn't matter right but if it makes
you feel better I would say yeah I think
whatever that Joy you're experiencing on
Earth you're gonna experience it like
10x a thousand and Beyond even if you
can imagine X in heaven what if when you
die
you know like all of a sudden it's just
like pitch black and then like a thing
appears in front of you and it says like
congratulations on completing life would
you like to end game or New Game Plus
and then when you select new game plus
you're like you're born again but you
remember everything and you have all of
your knowledge but you're like a newborn
baby awesome new game plus I got a
feeling that your electromagnetic field
your human Dynamo is where your spirit
is stored and when you die it goes out
into the atmosphere that's kind of like
purgatory and if you're just obsessed
with Earth and you can't let go you stay
and you become a demon and you're in
hell but if you let yourself go you go
into the Sun and become one with it and
that's where Heaven exists at least
locally then maybe the galactic core
yeah you can at some point go about that
where it was like uh there are gods and
our God is within the Sun and Heaven Was
within the Sun but that also means that
every other star was a different kind of
like deity or power what's always
comforted me about heaven is you know in
my faith is that everything because
there's sometimes I think and there's a
kind of a cultural imagination about
heaven that it's boring you know like
angel with a harp or something I don't
know if you guys have ever run into that
but or it's like weird or something but
like the God who created all the good
things of Earth created the Perfection
of heaven and himself who you know God
and create himself he is you know
forever always has been but God is
perfect and communion with God will be
just mind-blowingly amazingly amazing
and so you kind of don't have to worry
about it right because it's going to be
amazing
but I think sometimes we doubt that
because we can't imagine how amazing
it's going to be but we just have to
trust and life can be so good sometimes
I understand why people don't want to
let go
let's read some more we got um Acadia
says Louisiana made a new law called
Covenant marriage it's only between a
man and a woman there are extra steps
but it's what marriage is supposed to be
only dissolved under certain
circumstances super marriage I called
for super marriage yep on this show I
said you guys can keep your no-fault
divorce but we'll just create something
called super marriage which is
effectively married without no fault
divorce you can get married in the
Catholic church that's Super Mario you
can always choose or not no divorce for
that so no one force you get married if
you get married in the Catholic Church
it is that what they're describing at
Super marriage because no you're not
allowed to ever divorce you can get a
legal divorce for separation if there's
like abuse or something but if it was an
actual marriage not if there's no
annulment meaning annulment is when it
wasn't a marriage and you thought it was
but the person was lying to you or
there's some other extreme circumstance
but once married always married all
right Triton 54 says the Hunter Court
drama is much more nefarious Hunter's
attorney Jessica Bengals Hunter's
attorney contacted the court pretending
to represent the house Ways and Means
Committee in order to get motions
removed from the docket I heard that
isn't that crazy yeah we add some dark
stuff
how did that Jacob says I don't know if
Hunter is the diversion for the aliens
or vice versa but we are definitely part
of a Psy up one way or the other
aliens are diversion for Hunter
it's all a diversion for the biggest
issues of the day which are not that I
would like regrowing the coral reefs
yeah yeah dude all right you hear that
uh the water in Florida was over 100
degrees
it's like a hot tub just on the beach
John Bartholomew says Tim my firstborn
son is five days old and is enjoying his
first Tim cast IRL tonight gotta get him
young you know I gotta hook him young
thank you for all you do to shift the
culture of our country in a direction
that gives me hope for my son thank you
very much good job being born man nice
work that's a hard job yeah it's tough
gravity is annoying guys we're gonna
learn to walk it'll be awesome
Jedi mind trick says Ian I've heard you
many times say I'm not sure if it's a
human in regard to abortion my question
would be what other species than a human
have women ever give birth to using
deductive logic what what the WTF else
could it be well that's the Chimera we
talked about maybe the chat came in
early humans no woman has ever given
birth to Chimera so that's that's
arguably not true the the the potential
what are you defining that to be
actually because so the The Legend goes
that the Soviet Legends okay so it and
there's there's a reason to believe it
may be true the Soviets were conducting
experiments where they were trying to
create human chimp hybrids the issue is
that you can't take male sperm and put
it into a female chimp because a female
chimp is too small it would have to be
chimp sperm in a female human who's
larger and can actually birth the baby
and many people call it a conspiracy
theory whatever you want
I would lean towards
these countries are running Black
Operations genetic experiments on humans
the Nazis were doing crazy stuff the
Japanese were doing crazy stuff they
would take a person put their arm into
freezing into like a freezing Sub-Zero
temperatures and then once it froze
shatter it to see what would happen so
they're doing stuff like that we know
about why wouldn't would they not try
and create a so the thing about a human
chimp hybrid is that humans and chimps
share almost all of their DNA like a
ridiculous like 99.4 or something so
when we hybridize say like a horse and a
donkey is that what it is horse and
Donkey makes a mule or whatever yes they
we can make hybrids between like ligers
and tions so humans and chimps
theoretically have enough DNA where it's
not the most advanced genetic
engineering to try and create this it's
just got to be a human woman carrying it
so so it there's no I think it happened
there's no evidence that it's been
successfully done but if it were
successfully done to your point Tim it
would be wrong and it should be illegal
to kill or harm in any way that at
chimera it's a hypothetical hybrid of
chimps and humans they say um serious
attempts to creature hybrid were made by
the Soviet biologist Ilya Ivanovich
Ivanov in the 1920s and possibly by
researchers in China in the 1960s though
neither succeeded I kind of feel like
there's no reason for them not to have
continued they share 95 of the DNA
sequence and 99 of coding DNA sequences
there you go there it is hybridization
between chimps and bonobos has already
been documented but here's the thing we
should not be permitting experimentation
on new human embryos or creating new
human embryos in IVF petri dishes until
then
in China and in the Soviet Union so
again I know it happens in other
countries I'm talking about our country
because for all the experimentation
you're talking about Tim like we're
doing experimentation here and it's
funded by the NIH what do you think
about like crispr I don't know how much
time we don't have much time to get into
it maybe we talk about the after show
like the idea of genetic editing to give
people better eyesight or something yeah
Frost we got to go to the members only
we'll talk about we'll talk about it
there we're gonna go late so sorry but
uh if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends go to timcast.com click join us
become a member the members only show is
coming up in a few minutes you can
follow the show at timcastirl you can
follow me personally at timcast Lila do
you want to shout anything out thanks
check out liveaction.org and I've got a
podcast Violet Rose podcast on YouTube
right on I am Philly remains official on
Twitter uh the band is All That Remains
uh
uh Spotify
on YouTube Pandora Pandora Apple music
the whole you know all the places so I'm
Ian Crossland you guys thank you for
coming have a great night Lila thanks
for coming thank you tone helped a lot I
think what you were saying earlier Phil
you can't tell someone don't have sex
but sometimes just hearing the tone of
people can can change you when you're
young so thank you Roseanne changed me
when I was young for instance with her
awesome show so thanks for coming on
talking about it man we need more
conversations like this thanks for
having me what's happening Serge not
much what an interesting chat uh I am
surge.com I'm on Twitter I'm all over
the place uh follow me there let's fight
and argue on the Internet it's great we
will see you all over at timcast.com in
a couple minutes thanks for hanging out